Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, add free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to the rest is history.com and join the club. That is the rest is history.com. This episode is presented by Adobe Express, the quick and easy create-anything app. What does that mean? Well, say you need to make a presentation or a video or a social media post or a flyer to some, certainly to me, that sounds intimidating. But Tom, with Adobe Express's intuitive features like templates, generative AI and real-time collaboration, it has never been easier. Adobe Express. Try it for free. Search Adobe Express in the App Store.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest is History）。想要获取每周的独家播客内容、无广告收听、系列节目的提前试听权限，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问therestisistory.com并加入俱乐部。网址是therestisistory.com。本期节目由Adobe Express赞助，这是一款快速、简便、能创作任何内容的应用程序。这是什么意思？比如说，你需要制作一个演示文稿、一个视频、一篇社交媒体帖子或一张传单，对某些人来说——尤其是对我来说——这听起来让人望而生畏。但是，汤姆，有了Adobe Express直观的功能，比如模板、生成式AI和实时协作，这一切从未如此简单。Adobe Express，免费试用。在应用商店中搜索Adobe Express。
Wendy's most important deal of the day has a fresh lineup. Pick any two breakfast items for $4. New four-piece French toast sticks, bacon or sausage wrap, biscuit or English muffin sandwiches, small hot coffee, and more. Limited time only at participating Wendy's Taxes Extra. I'm Chris Hadfield, astronaut and citizen of planet Earth. Join me on a journey into the systems that power the world. No politics, just real conversations with real people shaping the future of energy. Listen wherever you get your podcasts. Until he has experienced all the intricacies of war with his own eyes, his own body and his own soul, no man can ever truly imagine it.
温蒂汉堡（Wendy's）当天的头号优惠带来了全新的阵容。只需4美元即可任选两款早餐食品。全新的四片法式吐司条、培根或香肠卷、饼干或英式松饼三明治、小杯热咖啡等。活动限时推出，仅限参与活动的温蒂汉堡门店，税费另计。我是克里斯·哈德菲尔德（Chris Hadfield），一名宇航员和地球公民。和我一起踏上一段旅程，去探索驱动这个世界的系统。没有政治，只有与塑造能源未来的真实人物进行的真实对话。在您获取播客的任何平台上收听。在亲眼目睹、亲身体验并亲身经历战争的所有错综复杂之前，没有人能真正想象它。
Marching through sand and marshland through fathomless swampy forests in the heating heat with no water in his stomach groaning in hunger. And then suddenly, as you were plodding along so tired and bruised and battered, the scene comes alive before you. The first shots of barking in your ears and the roaring and howling of the shells is getting nearer and nearer. To one side you hear the crackling of machine gun fire. You taste the battle, a peculiar sour yet bland taste that settles in your mouth and you feel it because all your nerves and muscles contract and your brain can think of one thing and one thing only. You have to act. So that is from the thrillingly titled Kaiser Yeager, Persevere, the heroic death of the second regiment of the
在酷热中穿过沙地和沼泽，穿过深不可测的泥泞森林，腹中无水，饥肠辘辘。然后突然间，当你疲惫不堪、伤痕累累地艰难前行时，眼前的景象活了过来。第一批枪声在耳边犬吠，炮弹的轰鸣和呼啸声越来越近。在一侧，你可以听到机枪扫射的噼啪声。你品尝到了战争的味道——一种奇特、酸涩却又乏味的滋味在口中弥漫开来，你能感觉得到，因为你所有的神经和肌肉都在收缩，你的大脑只能思考一件事，而且只能是一件事：你必须采取行动。这段话摘自那本拥有令人兴奋的书名《蒂罗尔狩猎兵团：克尔塞维尔，第二团的英雄之死》
Tyrolean Kaiser Yeager in the days of September 1914. It was published in the late 1930s and is quoted in Nick Lloyd's new book on the Eastern Front. And Dominant, you have written, we've always had a soft spot for the Tyrolean, Kaiser Yeager, an elite regiment, the Imperial Hunters with lovely sky blue uniforms and feathered hats. Now,
蒂罗尔皇家狩猎兵团在1914年9月的日子。它出版于20世纪30年代末，被尼克·劳埃德（Nick Lloyd）关于东线的新书所引用。多米尼克，你写过，我们一直对蒂罗尔皇家狩猎兵团情有独钟，这是一支精锐部队，“帝国猎手”，穿着可爱的天蓝色制服，戴着羽毛帽子。现在，
I've never had a soft spot for the Tyrolean, Kaiser Yeager, because I've never even heard of them. But as I said in the previous episode, we are now on your home territory. This is a part of the world, you know like the back of your hand, you've roamed the mountains,
我从来没有对蒂罗尔皇家狩猎兵团情有独钟，因为我甚至都没听说过他们。但正如我在上一集里所说，我们现在来到了你的主场。这是世界上的一片土地，你对它了如指掌，你曾在山间漫步，
you've plunged into the depths of the, forests. You speak all the languages. This is your home territory. So tell us what's going on here. Who are the Turillian Kaiser Yeager? What is it with their lovely sky blue uniforms and their feathered hats? What's going on? Is it the hell of war or what? I imagine it is probably because everything in this series seems to be about the hell of war. But surprise us. It is the hell of war, Tom. And actually, Tom, you're being falsely modest because you, even before we did the rest of history, You used to talk to me about the second regiments in particular of the Tyrolean Kaysiaga. They're your favorite regiments of your favorite Austro-Hungarian unit and don't deny it.
你曾深入森林腹地。你会说所有的语言。这是你的主场。所以，给我们讲讲这里发生了什么。蒂罗尔皇家狩猎兵团是什么人？他们可爱的天蓝色制服和羽毛帽子是怎么回事？到底怎么了？这是战争的地狱还是别的什么？我想大概是的，因为这个系列中的一切似乎都与战争的地狱有关。不过，给我们一个惊喜吧。这就是战争的地狱，汤姆。事实上，汤姆，你是在故作谦虚，因为甚至在我们制作《历史的余烬》之前，你就经常跟我谈起蒂罗尔皇家狩猎兵团的第二团。它们是你最喜欢的奥匈帝国部队中你最喜欢的团，别否认。
I am hiding my light under a bushel here. But I only say that you will blaze all the more brightly. That's kind. Generosity. I think it's the feathered hats that do it for us, isn't it? So actually, yes, the Tyrolin Kayser Yeager had a terrible time in the September 1914. What happens to them is just one aspect of a wider story. So we began this series more than a year ago with.
我在这里只是韬光养晦罢了。但我这么说，只会让你显得更加光芒耀眼。真好，太慷慨了。我想是那些羽毛帽子让我们对它们印象深刻，对吧？所以，事实上，蒂罗尔皇家狩猎兵团在1914年9月遭遇了可怕的经历。发生在他们身上的事只是更广泛故事的一个方面。所以我们在一年前多开始了这系列节目，讲述的是……
Franz Ferdinand and his assassination in Sarajevo. And we're ending this part of our great sweep through the First World War by talking about the beginning of the end of Austria-Hungary, the destruction of its army and the fraying of the bonds that held the empire together. So last time we talked about how the Austrians sought to reap revenge on Serbia, and it became a humiliating route for them and the bloke in charge, General Pottyurek, the master of security in Sarajevo ended up being fired just before Christmas.
弗朗茨·斐迪南及其在萨拉热窝遇刺。我们通过讨论奥匈帝国的衰落之始、其军队的毁灭以及维系帝国纽带的破裂，来为我们纵览第一次世界大战的宏大篇章画上这一部分的句号。所以上一次我们讨论了奥地利人如何试图对塞尔维亚进行报复，结果却演变成了一场对他们而言奇耻大辱的溃败，而负责这一切的家伙——萨拉热窝的安全大师波蒂奥雷克（Potiorek）将军——在圣诞节前夕最终被解雇了。
And presumably after that, there are no feathers left in the hats of the Therleyan Kaiser Yeager. Not at all. And today we're turning to the arena in which they saw combat, which is the eastern borderlands of Poland and Ukraine. It's the area that Timothy Snyder calls Europe's bloodlands in the 20th century.
想必在那之后，蒂罗尔皇家狩猎兵团的帽子上就再也没有羽毛了吧？一点也没错。今天，我们将转向他们目睹战斗的竞技场，也就是波兰和乌克兰的东部边境地区。这就是蒂莫西·斯奈德（Timothy Snyder）所说的20世纪“欧洲的血地”。
And at the center of this episode is the story of one city, which is called Pshimishl. What's it called? It's called Shiemischel. So this was the most formidable fortress of the Austro-Hungarian Empire, and the struggle for this fortress became the longest siege of the war. And I have to be honest with the listeners,
本集的中心是一座城市的历史，它叫普热梅希尔（Przemyśl）。叫什么？叫普热梅希尔。这是奥匈帝国最强大的要塞，而争夺这座要塞的战斗成为了战争中历时最长的围城战。我必须对听众们坦白，
the reason I know about this is because I read a brilliant book called The Fortress by the historian Alexander Watson. So just a massive shout-out to this book, The Fortress, because so much of what follows is dependent upon it. It's a story that's not just a riveting story in and of itself, but it captures the collapse of the Austro-Hungarian Empire. and then by centuries of history, the ethnic cleansing of Eastern Europe and the agony of the Jews of Poland and Ukraine, which begins really here. So to give a sense of where we are, I'm sure this will immediately help you out, Tom, but I tell you, they were in the Kingdom of Galicia and Lodomiria.
我之所以知道这一点，是因为我读了一本由历史学家亚历山大·沃森（Alexander Watson）所著的精彩书籍，名为《要塞》（The Fortress）。所以，必须向这本《要塞》致以崇高的敬意，因为后面讲述的很多内容都依赖于它。这个故事不仅本身引人入胜，而且它捕捉到了奥匈帝国的崩溃，以及随后的几个世纪的历史、东欧的种族清洗，以及波兰和乌克兰犹太人的痛苦——这一切其实都从这里开始。为了让大家对我们所处的位置有个概念，我确信这会立刻对你有所帮助，汤姆，但我告诉你，他们当时身处加利西亚和洛多梅里亚王国。
Of course we are. So today, Eastern Poland, that's where Bashimichel is, very close to the Ukrainian border. Now, at the time, this was Austria's most northeastern province. crown land, so called, governed from Vienna. And the province of Galicia had two big cities. One is a place then called Lemberg, but which we know is Leviv, and the other is Krakoff, now in southeastern Poland. The area had a very diverse population. So about 45% each Polish, and what was then called Ruthenian, what we would now call Ukrainian, and that leaves about 10% which those people were Jewish. And the third biggest city in Galicia was this place, Jemichel.
我们当然身处其中。所以今天的波兰东部，普热梅希尔就在那里，紧邻乌克兰边境。在当时，这是奥地利最东北部的省份，所谓的“皇冠领地”，由维也纳管辖。加利西亚省有两座大城。一座是当时被称为伦贝格（Lemberg）的地方，也就是我们现在所知的利沃夫（Lviv）；另一座是克拉科夫（Kraków），现在位于波兰东南部。该地区的人口非常多元化。波兰人和当时被称为“鲁塞尼语族”（我们现在所说的乌克兰人）各占约45%，这就剩下大约10%的犹太人。加利西亚的第三大城市就是这个地方，普热梅希尔。
I love hearing you say that. And today, it's just a few miles in from the Polish border with Ukraine. What's it called now? Still called that. It's still called Jemischel. That's the Polish name. And it was given an award by Vladimir Zelensky a couple of years ago for taking so many refugees, so many Ukrainian refugees. But back then in 1914, in most respects, it was just your classic, sleepy, middle European city.
我喜欢听你这么说。而今天，它距离波兰与乌克兰的边境只有几英里。它现在叫什么？依然叫那个名字。它仍然叫普热梅希尔。那是波兰语的名字。几年前，它还因接纳了如此多的难民、如此多的乌克兰难民而获得了弗拉基米尔·泽连斯基颁发的奖项。但在那时的1914年，在大多数方面，它只是你所能想象的那个经典、宁静的中欧城市。
So it's got a castle and its cathedral. It's got loads of churches. It's got synagogues. and it's got tons of coffee houses. And there were about 50,000 people who lived there. About half of them were Catholics and were Polish. About a third were Jewish. And the rest were what were then called kind of Greek Catholics,
它有一座城堡和一座大教堂。它有无数的教堂。它有犹太会堂，还有数不清的咖啡馆。当时那里大约有5万人口。其中大约一半是天主教徒和波兰人。大约三分之一是犹太人。其余的则是当时被称为“希腊天主教徒”的人，
which is to say they're Ukrainians. So they're Orthodox, but they accept the supremacy of the papacy. Is that right? Exactly right. Yeah. But there was also a garrison of about 10,000 men for a couple of reasons. First of all, because Jemish was an important railway. junction, and it guarded the Carpathian mountain passes into Hungary. So if you look at a map
也就是乌克兰人。所以他们是东正教徒，但他们承认教皇的至高无上地位。是这样吗？完全正确。是的。但这里也驻扎着大约1万人的卫戍部队，原因有二。首先，因为普热梅希尔是一个重要的铁路枢纽，它守卫着通往匈牙利的喀尔巴阡山脉山口。如果你看一下地图，
of Austria-Hungary, in the northeast, there's the great sweep of the Carpathian mountains, but they're not the border. There's a bit of Austria-Hungary that's on the other side of the Carpavians, and this is Galicia, so this is where this is. And the second reason why there's this garrison is that since the early 1870s, Pradeshul had been designated as a fortress city, so it was designated as the cornerstone of Austria-Hungary's eastern defences. So it's kind of It's kind of the Verdun of Austro-Hungary. It is Verdun, exactly, a citadel that becomes an emblem of national defence, national security. And kind of a salient.
奥匈帝国的东北部是绵延宏伟的喀尔巴阡山脉，但它们并不是边界。奥匈帝国有一部分位于喀尔巴阡山脉的另一侧，这就是加利西亚，所以这就是这个地方所在的位置。设立这支卫戍部队的第二个原因是，自19th世纪70年代初以来，普热梅希尔就被指定为一座要塞城市，因此它被指定为奥匈帝国东部防御的基石。所以它有点像是——它有点像是奥匈帝国的凡尔登。它就是凡尔登，没错，一个成为国家防御、国家安全象征的堡垒。而且有点像是一个突出部。
Yeah, salians, I guess. Osgiliath, Tom, for Gondor, I guess. So by 1914, they've built this huge fortress, and it's a chain of 17 major and 18 minor forts, arranged in a 30-mile ring around the city and two lines of trenches. So it looks pretty impregnable. And inside this ring, there's a huge military base of seven barracks with a rail yard, with warehouses, with ammunition magazines. All of this cost, the Austro-Hungarians, hundreds and hundreds of millions of pounds in today's money.
对，突出部，我猜吧。汤姆，奥斯吉力亚斯（Osgiliath），为了刚铎，我猜是这样。所以在1914年，他们已经建成了这座巨大的要塞，它由17个主要堡垒和18个次要堡垒组成的链条环绕着这座城市，形成了一个30英里宽的环形防线以及两道战壕。所以它看起来相当坚不可摧。在这个环形防线内部，有一个巨大的军事基地，拥有七个军营、一个铁路编组站、仓库和弹药库。所有这些，用今天的货币计算，花掉了奥匈帝国数以亿计的英镑。
And Shemichel has become this huge symbol of imperial prestige, and the Austrians are very, very proud of it. Well, it sounds as if they should be. Sounds brilliant. Yeah, it's the equivalent of having, like, a really fancy aircraft carrier today or something of that ilk. So, to the war. In August 1914, tens of thousands of troops passed through this city heading east to the far
普热梅希尔已经成为帝国威望的巨大象征，奥地利人对此感到非常非常自豪。嗯，听起来他们确实应该如此。听起来很棒。是的，这就相当于今天拥有一艘非常豪华的航空母舰或类似的东西。那么，说到战争。在1914年8月，成千上万的军队穿过这座城市，向东前往
border of Galicia to defend it against the Russians. And as we said in the last episode, they were a very complicated mosaic of Germans, Hungarians, Czechs, Poles, whatever. Not a winning formula under the pressure of total war. And of course, the man who's commanding them is this bloke, Conrad von Hudsondorf, who is basically He started a world war in order to impress his mistress, Gene of Unrininghouse, and to get to marry her. Now, Conrad, as we said in the last episode, when we talked about the complete disaster of the war against Serbia, he is a great believer in attacking spirit. Even though the Austrians have fewer divisions than the Russians, they have 34, the Russians have 53, he thinks that's fine, we can easily, you know, Tim and Vigo, we'll wipe the floor with the Russians.
加利西亚的远东边界，以防范俄国人。正如我们在上一集所说，他们是一群非常复杂的德国人、匈牙利人、捷克人、波兰人等的马赛克拼图。在总体战的压力下，这绝不是一个能获胜的配方。当然，指挥他们的这个人就是康拉德·冯·赫岑多夫（Conrad von Hötzendorf），他基本上……为了给他的情妇吉娜·冯·赖宁豪斯（Gina von Reininghaus）留下深刻印象并娶她为妻，他发动了一次世界大战。现在，康拉德，正如我们在上一集讨论对塞尔维亚战争的彻底灾难时所说的那样，他坚定地信仰进攻精神。尽管奥地利人的师级部队比俄国人少——他们有34个师，而俄国人有53个师——但他认为这没问题，我们可以轻松地……蒂姆和维戈（Tim and Vigo），我们会把俄国人打得落花流水。
So he's developed this insanely ambitious plan to basically envelop the Russians in southern Poland. But right from the start, as is the way with the Austro-Hungarian military operations, there are some small teething troubles. So first of all, he says, well, I'll need 11,000 trains to send all these men east. The train network can only produce 2,000 trains. So that's nowhere near enough. These trains travel at only 10 miles an hour, and they stop for six hours every day, said the troops can have lunch.
因此，他制定了一个极其雄心勃勃的计划，基本上是要在波兰南部包围俄国人。但从一开始，正如奥匈帝国军事行动的一贯作风，就有一些小小的初期麻烦。首先，他说，好吧，我需要11,000列火车来把所有这些人运往东方。铁路网只能提供2,000列火车。所以这远远不够。这些火车的时速只有10英里，而且每天停驶六个小时，据说是为了让部队吃午饭。
Before they even fire a shot, there are warning signs. So at one point, they're all these troops going east, and the station master at a place called Pold Borgia, which is in eastern Silesia, has a nervous breakdown under the stress of so many people on the network. He reverses all the signals the wrong way. The trains will go backwards and then he shoots himself. Do you know what they should have had? A monkey. Jack the signalman. Jack the signalman.
甚至在他们开枪之前，就已经有警告信号了。所以在某个时刻，所有的军队都在向东进发，位于东西里西亚一个叫波尔德博吉亚（Pold Borgia）的地方的车站长，在网络上聚集了如此多的人的压力下精神崩溃了。他把所有的信号灯都反方向拨错。火车开始倒退，然后他开枪自杀。你知道他们应该配备什么吗？一只猴子。信号员杰克。信号员杰克。
They should have had a monkey. He had one of his just top monkeys. Because he never made a mistake, paid him beer, ran the South African railways for years. Yeah. He was brilliant. And for those who may have missed that episode, and we'd like to hear it again, it's episode 426, history's greatest monkeys. And I wasn't actually expecting them to turn up in the middle of the First World War, but you never know. Well, one of them fought in the First World War.
他们应该有一只猴子。他有一只顶级猴子。因为它从来没犯过错，给它啤酒喝，运营了南非铁路多年。是的。它太棒了。对于那些可能错过那一集、还想再听一遍的人来说，那是第426集：《历史上最伟大的猴子》。我其实没料到它们会在第一次世界大战期间出现，但你永远猜不到。好吧，其中一只确实参加了第一次世界大战。
Corporal Jackie. Great to have him back on the show. Anyway, back to the Eastern Front. Eventually, they get off the trains and they set off. Now, Eastern Galicia is a very poor, very rural part of the empire. There actually aren't many railways, and the roads are shocking. And most Habsburg soldiers, when they get there, they say, God, this is awful. This is very hot and it's dusty and it's very alien and what are we doing here?
杰基下士（Corporal Jackie）。很高兴他回到节目中。言归正传，回到东线。最终，他们下了火车，出发了。现在，东加利西亚是帝国一个非常贫困、非常乡村的地区。那里其实没有多少铁路，道路也糟糕透顶。大多数哈布斯堡王朝的士兵到达那里时都会说：“天哪，这太糟糕了。这里又热又多尘，非常陌生，我们在这里做什么？”
They won't a couple of early victories against the Russians, actually, which we won't go into. But by the end of August, things are starting to go wrong. The language difficulty is such a massive issue for them. They can't actually understand what each other are saying. So the orders are getting muddled. Some units literally are marching in these vast circles going to go. It's going round and round. Or they lose touch with their supplies or whatever.
他们确实对俄国人取得了几场早期的胜利，不过我们就不细说了。但到了8月底，事情开始出岔子了。语言障碍对他们来说是个巨大的问题。他们实际上听不懂彼此在说什么。因此，命令变得一团糟。有些部队字面意义上是在漫无目的地绕着大圈子行军。转来转去。或者他们失去了与补给的联系，诸如此类。
And because of the language difficulty, there are innumerable instances, and this is not funny, of friendly fire. So, you know, a load of Croats will bump into a load of checks and they'll start shooting to each other because they think the others are Russians or Germans and Hungarians or whatever. So all this chaos is unfolding. So, Dominic, can I just ask, they don't all have a standard uniform then? Do they have, do the different units have different uniforms? Well, of course, different, yeah. They're not all got feathered hats like the Tira and Kaiser Yeager, where they're scar. blue uniforms. Yeah, so there is scope for complication there. There's definite scope for complications.
而且由于语言障碍，发生了无数起——这可不好笑——友军误伤事件。所以，你知道，一堆克罗地亚人会撞上一堆捷克人，然后他们就会开始向对方开枪，因为他们以为对方是俄国人，或者德国人和匈牙利人，等等。因此，所有的混乱都在上演。所以，多米尼克，请问，难道他们当时没有统一的制服吗？不同部队的制服不一样吗？当然，不同，是的。他们并非都像蒂罗尔皇家狩猎兵团那样戴着羽毛帽子、穿着天蓝色制服。是的，所以这里确实有产生混乱的空间。绝对有产生混乱的空间。
Now, meanwhile, far to the east, the Russians are building up their forces, and soon they outnumber the Austrians, almost two to one. Now, back in Jemish, people have no idea what's, the troops have been and gone, and people have no idea what's happening at the front. And then in late August, the first trains of wounded start to arrive in the city. And a woman who was serving hot drinks to the wounded at the station, later described the spectacle. She said, I saw shot through lungs and hearts, terrible stomach wounds, blood, vomit, feces, but not a single groan, just apathy. Then on the 30th of August, for the first time they hear,
现在，与此同时，在远东地区，俄国人正在集结他们的军队，很快他们的兵力就达到了奥地利人的近两倍。现在，回到普热梅希尔，人们完全不知道——部队已经来了又走，人们对前线发生了什么一无所知。然后到了8月下旬，第一批满载伤员的火车开始抵达这座城市。一位在车站为伤员提供热饮的妇女后来描述了当时的惨状。她说：“我看到被子弹击穿的肺部和心脏，可怕的腹部伤口，鲜血、呕吐物、粪便，但没有一声呻吟，只有麻木。”然后到了8月30日，他们第一次听到……
you call it the crump, I call it the dull thud, of guns in the east. So the front is clearly coming closer. Then, an extraordinary scene, a train comes through Shemichel carrying Russian prisoners, And as it rolls through the station, a man shoves his head out of the window of the train, and he screams out in Polish. Oh, you poor, poor people, a great power is coming towards you. They will murder you. God, it really, I mean, it really is like a kind of horror film, isn't it? The zombies are approaching.
你称之为“砰”的爆炸声，我称之为东方的沉闷隆隆声。所以前线显然在逼近。接着，一个极其离奇的场景出现了，一列载着俄国战俘的火车穿过普热梅希尔，当它驶过车站时，一个人把头伸出车窗，用波兰语大喊大叫：“哦，你们这些可怜、可怜的人，一股巨大的力量正向你们逼近。他们会杀了你们的。”天哪，这真的——我的意思是，这真的有点像恐怖电影，不是吗？僵尸在逼近。
Well, exactly. So next come a whole load of trains from Liviv. Leviv is 60 miles away in the east, on the eastern frontier of the empire. And these trains are packed not with wounded men, but with civilian refugees. So it's now clear that something out east has gone horribly, horribly wrong. And actually when these refugees shout out at the trains and they say, Leviv is in chaos, the mayor or the officials have fled, the banks have shut down, the streets, the parks are full of wounded soldiers, there's no food, law and order have broken down completely.
完全正确。所以接下来开来了一整列从利沃夫开出的火车。利沃夫在东面60英里处，位于帝国的东部边境。这些火车上挤满的不是伤员，而是平民难民。所以现在很清楚，东方的某些事情已经出了大问题、大麻烦。事实上，当这些难民对着火车大喊大叫，说利沃夫陷入混乱，市长或官员们已经逃跑，银行已经关门，街道和公园里挤满了受伤的士兵，没有食物，法律和秩序已经彻底崩溃时，一切都昭然若揭。
It is a bit of a zombie film. And then there are no more trains. It's as though communications with Leviv have completely gone down because Galicia's capital, LeViv, has fallen to the Russians. Hello, hello, can you hear me? Can you hear me? Exactly like that. It is like that. I wonder what was going on there at first and then I thought, no, that's great acting.
这有点像部丧尸片，然后火车就没有了。就像与利沃夫的通讯完全中断了一样，因为加利西亚的首府利沃夫已经落入俄国人手中。喂，喂，能听到我说话吗？能听到我说话吗？完全就是这样。就是这种感觉。我一开始还在想那里到底发生了什么，后来我想，不对，这是精湛的演技。
It is. Brilliant. So what has gone wrong out east? What has gone wrong is this, that Conrad has thrown 600,000 men into action, but not enough. and they don't have enough good guns, and the Russians have completely steamrolled them. So, Leviv had fallen on the 3rd of September, occupied by General Alexei Brusilov's 8th Russian army, and that's just the beginning.
确实如此。太精彩了。那么东方出了什么问题？问题在于，康拉德投入了60万军队参战，但这还不够。而且他们没有足够的好枪，俄国人完全把他们碾压了。因此，利沃夫已于9月3日陷落，被阿列克谢·布鲁西洛夫将军率领的俄国第8集团军占领，而这仅仅是个开始。
Further north, the Russians are absolutely battering the Austrians at a base called Ravarouska. And so by the 9th of September, the Austrians are facing total and utter disintegration. And the next day, the 10th, General Conrad drove out himself to the front line with the Archduke Karl, the heir to the Austrian throne. So they went to a place called Grodeck. This was very unusual for Conrad because usually he's behind the lines. And he was absolutely horrified
更往北，俄国人在一个叫拉瓦罗斯卡的地方把奥地利人打得落花流水。因此到9月10日，奥地利人面临着彻底的崩溃。第二天，即9月10日，康拉德将军带着奥地利皇位继承人卡尔大公亲自驱车前往前线。他们去了一个叫格罗代克的地方。这对于康拉德来说非常罕见，因为他通常都待在后方。他感到大受震撼
by what he found, the total chaos. And one thing above all, in Grodeck, there were six bodies hanging in the main square. Two of them accused of betraying Austrians to the enemy and the others for robbing the dead and the wounded on the battlefield.
面对他所发现的一切，那种彻底的混乱。最重要的一点是，在格罗代克的主广场上挂着六具尸体。其中两人被控向敌人出卖奥地利人，其他人则被控在战场上抢劫死伤者的财物。
So a very sort of, a very kind of haunting scene. Conrad goes up to the highest ridge to survey the battlefield, and even he can, with his optimism, can see that the Russians are about to break through. So the following night, the 11th, he gives the order to fall back behind the river San, which is one of the rivers in sort of south-eastern Poland. And the next day, the Austrians began to retreat.
所以这是一种非常、非常令人挥之不去的场景。康拉德走到最高山脊上察看战场，即使以他的乐观，他也能看出俄国人即将突破防线。因此在接下来的夜晚，即11日，他下令撤退到散河后面，那是东南部波兰的一条河流。第二天，奥地利军队开始撤退。
And the same day, you know, perfect timing, the clouds open, the rain starts coming down. Tom, the heavens are weeping for the Habsburg Empire. And presumably for Conrad's relationship with Gina, because she's not going to be impressed by this, told, is she? Well, the news actually gets much worse for Conrad. Five days after he'd given the order to retreat, his adjutant came into his office looking very, very stricken. Conrad said, what, more bad news than the front, really? And the adjutant said, it's actually a personal matter for you, sir, kind of concerning your son. And Conrad said, oh, no, please tell me he's not badly wounded. And the adjutant said, no, it's worse than that. So Conrad's youngest and his
就在同一天，你知道的，时机刚刚好，乌云密布，大雨倾盆。汤姆，苍天在为哈布斯堡王朝哭泣。大概也是在为康拉德和吉娜的关系哭泣，因为她对这个可不会有什么好印象，对吧？好吧，对康拉德来说，消息实际上变得更糟了。在他下令撤退五天后，他的副官走进办公室，神情非常、非常痛苦。康拉德问，怎么，前线又有坏消息了吗？副官说，其实这是一件关于您个人的私事，长官，似乎跟您的儿子有关。康拉德说，哦，不，请告诉我他伤得不重。副官说，不，比那更糟。所以康拉德最小且最
favorite son, who was called Herbert, was a lieutenant in the dragoons, and he had been killed at Ravaruska. And Conrad says to the adjutant, can you leave me a minute? And for an hour, he wept. And then he washed his face, and he straightened his uniform, and he went back to work, as though nothing had happened. But everybody said that after this, he was basically a broken man, a kind of withdrawn and broken man. But he doesn't lose his job. He carries on running the Austrian army. And even before that, he'd been melancholy, hadn't he? Because there was that war, war, war. Yeah, exactly.
疼爱的儿子，名叫赫伯特，是龙骑兵部队的一名中尉，他在拉瓦罗斯卡阵亡了。康拉德对副官说，你能让我单独待一会儿吗？有一个小时，他都在哭泣。然后他洗了脸，整理好军服，又回去工作了，就好像什么都没发生过一样。但每个人都说，在这之后，他基本上成了一个破碎的人，一个孤僻而破碎的人。但他并没有失去工作。他继续指挥奥地利军队。而且在此之前，他就已经很忧郁了，不是吗？因为那时候到处都是战争、战争、战争。是的，完全如此。
His misery must be even greater. Yeah, he doesn't lose his job. He carries on making decisions, which unfortunately is disastrous for the Austrian cause. Do you think anyone could have stabilized the situation? They must be up against it. I was thinking about this actually when I was doing the notes. Because, you know, I'm quite ostracile.
他的悲惨处境一定更严重了。是的，他没有丢掉工作。他继续做出那些不幸地给奥地利事业带来灾难的决定。你认为当时有人能稳定局势吗？他们一定面临着绝境。其实我在做笔记时就在想这件事。因为，你知道的，我这人挺顽固的。
You are. Yeah, which is why I've been surprised by these two episodes because they haven't come out of it well. No, and I think, see, I don't blame the Austrians for starting the first world. I think any serious power... Faced with the murder of their air, clearly with the connivance of a country that's basically trying to destabilise them. You know, the United States, France, whoever, they're all going to respond. However, the irresponsibility is to respond when basically you don't have the capacity to beat anybody.
你是的。对，这也是为什么我对这两集感到惊讶，因为他们的表现并不好。不，而且我觉得，看吧，我不怪奥地利人挑起第一次世界大战。我认为任何一个严肃的大权在握的国家……面对继承人的谋杀，而这显然是一个基本上试图颠覆他们的国家的默许。你知道的，美国、法国，无论谁，都会作出反应。然而，不负责任的地方在于，在基本上没有能力击败任何人的情况下做出反应。
The Austrians couldn't even beat Serbia. The lack of seriousness of Conrad and the other generals basically in starting all this. I mean, ignoring Russia is mad, isn't it? Totally. It is ridiculous. And you can say, well, it's a result of their tunnel vision or the paranoia or their fear of, you know, disintegration or whatever, but even so, to just be in such a massive spasm of panic that you basically press the suicide button is insane. Because actually just, I mean, I was
奥地利人甚至连塞尔维亚都打不过。康拉德和其他将军在挑起这一切时缺乏严肃态度。我的意思是，忽视俄国简直是疯了，对吧？完全是。这太荒谬了。你可以说，这不过是他们思想狭隘、偏 paranoia（偏执）或是对分裂的恐惧等等造成的后果，但即便如此，陷入如此巨大的恐慌痉挛以至于基本上按下自杀按钮，也是疯狂的。因为实际上，我的意思是，我
going to talk about this anyway, but this is a perfect link. Look at what happened to their army. Almost a million men had marched north against the Russians and fewer than two-thirds of them return. A hundred thousand of them were taken prisoner, 250,000 killed or wounded. And as they return, you know, you made the zombie apocalypse analogy. The Austro-Hum, Hungarian army that marches back to Prishimishal is just an absolute horde of zombies stumbling through the dust. They've all got typhus or cholera. Some of the regiments have lost all their officers, more than half their men. They've all got diarrhea. They haven't washed for weeks. They're in shock. They're humiliated. And in the dust behind them, they're leaving
本来就要谈到这个，但这绝对是一个完美的衔接。看看他们的军队遭遇了什么。近百万士兵向北挺进对抗俄国人，而回来的人不到三分之二。其中十万人被俘，二十五万人阵亡或受伤。当他们撤回时，你知道的，你刚才用了僵尸末光的比喻。撤回普热梅希尔的奥匈帝国军队简直就是一群跌跌撞撞穿过尘埃的僵尸大队。他们全都感染了斑疹伤寒或霍乱。有些团失去了所有的军官，甚至过半的士兵。他们全都腹泻。好几个星期没洗澡了。他们处于震惊之中。他们饱受羞辱。而在他们身后的尘土中，他们留下了
this trail of dying horses and dead men. So they get back to this city. And then Conrad says, right, We will withdraw, we'll go back into the Carpathian mountains. However, we have to stop the Russians from following us. Because if the Russians get into these mountains and they secure the passes and they go down the other side, they'll be into the Hungarian plane, they'll be heading straight for Budapest, and then it's kind of game over for the Austrian Empire. And that would then be game over for Germany as well, do you think? Germany fighting on alone for a cause in which its main allies,
这条垂死马匹和阵亡士兵的轨迹。所以他们回到了这座城市。然后康拉德说，好，我们要撤退，我们要退回喀尔巴阡山脉。然而，我们必须阻止俄国人尾随我们。因为如果俄国人进入这些山脉并控制了山口，然后穿到另一边，他们就会进入匈牙利平原，直奔布达佩斯，接着对奥地利帝国来说基本上就game over（玩完）了。你认为那对德国来说也会是game over吗？德国为了一个其主要盟友在战争开始时就已经
start at the war is now out. It's hard to see how that. I mean, that could be the end of the First World War, I think, very plausibly. Conrad says, right, we have to stop them. And the place that we stop them is obviously the citadel, Jemichel, which we have built for this purpose. So I'm going to leave behind 130,000 men orders to hold the fortress at all costs. Now, these are not crack units. These are the dregs that he's leaving behind there.
出局的目标孤军奋战。很难看出这会怎么……我的意思是，这非常可能是第一次世界大战的结局，我认为。康拉德说，好吧，我们必须阻止他们。而我们阻止他们的地点，显然就是我们为此建造的堡垒——普热梅希尔。所以我将留下13万军队，下达不惜一切代价坚守要塞的命令。现在，这些可不是精锐部队。这些是他留在那里的残兵败旅。
The reserves, their men in their late 30s and early 40s. most of them are Hungarian, Polish, or Ukrainian peasants, but they're officers, Tom, they're the worst people in the world. And I quote, academics, businessmen, and middling state officials. I don't know. If you want a heroic defense of a fortress against Russian hordes, those are exactly the people I turn to. When I look at Brissons' academics, I see. I see men of high-end resolution and will. Anyway, yeah, so this is who's going to defend the Austrian empire. So in the next few days they make their preparations. Here's an interesting sign of the disintegration of the empire. They say we're going to clear all the villages around the perimeter.
预备役人员，三十多岁和四十出头的男人。他们大部分是匈牙利、波兰或乌克兰农民，但他们的军官，汤姆，他们是世界上最糟糕的人。我引述一下，“学者、商人和中层国家官员”。我不知道。如果你想要一场抵御俄国 hordes（大军）的英雄般的要塞保卫战，这正是我会求助的人。当我看到布里松的学者时，我看到的是……我看到的是具有极高决心和意志力的人。无论如何，是的，这就是将要保卫奥地利帝国的人。所以在接下来的几天里，他们做好了准备。这里有一个帝国解体的有趣迹象。他们说我们要清理周边所有的村庄。
Now, the people who live in these villages are Ukrainian peasants. And they basically say to these guys, you've got to clear out. Let's tell them at bayonet point. You've got to clear out. If you don't clear out, we're going to blow up your village or burn it to the ground. And actually, by this point, the soldiers are blaming those peasants for their own defeat. They say these Ukrainians are no good. They're traitors. They've been helping the Russians with flags, they've been sending smoke signals to the Russians. This, I think, is not true. But it's a sign of how, as we've said before, diversity is not the Austro-Hungarian Empire's strength at all. It's something that we often celebrate in the Austro- Hungarian Empire, you know, when people
现在，住在这些村庄里的人是乌克兰农民。他们基本上对这些人说，你们得滚蛋。用刺刀逼着他们。你们得滚蛋。如果不滚，我们就炸毁你们的村庄或将其烧为平地。事实上，到了这个时候，士兵们正在将他们自己的失败归咎于这些农民。他们说这些乌克兰人没用。他们是叛徒。他们一直在用旗帜帮助俄国人，他们一直在向俄国人发送烟雾信号。我认为这不是真的。但这表明了，正如我们之前所说，多元化根本不是奥匈帝国的优势。这是我们经常在奥匈帝国中赞美的某种东西，你知道的，当人们
write these sort of... Yeah, it's brilliant if you're in a cafe, debating psychology or economics, but it's less good if you have to defend a frontier. Correct. On the 17th of September, the first Cossacks appeared on the horizon. This was the advance guard of General Brousseloff's third Russian army. Brusilov is the outstanding Russian general of the war. He has yet another absolutely colossal moustache. But does he have breathing problems? No, he breathes superbly.
写这种……是的，如果你在咖啡馆里辩论心理学或经济学，这很棒，但如果你必须保卫边境，这就没那么好了。没错。9月17日，第一批哥萨克人出现在地平线上。这是布鲁西洛夫将军率领的俄国第三集团军的前卫。布鲁西洛夫是这场战争中杰出的俄国将军。他又留着一副绝对巨大的八字胡。但他有呼吸问题吗？不，他呼吸得极好。
He's got wonderful breath. So that's what sets him above the crowd? Correct. He's a cavalryman. It's half Polish, actually, Bruselof. I didn't know that. Anyway, so he orders his field guns to start pummeling the city. And when I say pummeling, I mean, they fired about 45,000 shells in four days.
他的呼吸太棒了。所以这就是让他脱颖而出的原因？没错。他是个骑兵。实际上，布鲁西洛夫有一半波兰血统。我不知道这一点。无论如何，他下令他的野战炮开始轰炸这座城市。当我说轰炸时，我的意思是，他们在四天内发射了大约45,000发炮弹。
which is obviously terrifying if you're a civilian, it was even worse for the people in these forts because they're very claustrophobic at these forts, people in these kind of low tunnels and chambers. Alexander Watson quotes a guy called Second Lieutenant Bruno Prochaska, who said it was like we were being pounded by a colossal battering ram.
如果你是个平民，这显然极其恐怖，而对于这些堡垒里的人来说就更糟了，因为这些堡垒非常令人幽闭恐惧，人们待在这些低矮的隧道和房间里。亚历山大·沃森引用了一个名叫布鲁诺·普罗查斯卡少尉的话，他说这感觉就像我们正被一根巨大的攻城槌猛烈撞击。
He said, we wish we were outside, actually, in the trenches. Death would be easier in the open air than in this cramped suffocating box. But actually, in the trenches, it's even worse. The shells are kind of raining down on these guys. he tells the story of an entire platoon which was destroyed by just two shells. The officers collapsed and fainted in shock
他说，其实我们真想待在外面战壕里。在开阔的空气中死区可能比在这个狭窄、窒息的盒子里要容易。但实际上，在战壕里情况更糟。炮弹像雨点一样砸向这些家伙。他讲述了一个排的故事，这个排仅仅被两发炮弹就给摧毁了。军官们看到所发生的一切震惊得晕厥过去
seeing what had happened to the men. One minute the men are all standing there. The next minute the men have been blown into bits and the bits are hanging from the trees all around them. So really hideous. Bloody shreds of flesh, intestine and brain parts. Yes. Yeah.
看着对士兵们发生的事情。前一分钟士兵们还都在那儿站着。后一分钟士兵们就被炸成了碎片，碎片挂在他们周围的树上。所以真的很可怕。血淋淋的血肉、内脏和大脑残片。是的。是的。
I decided not to read that out, but you read it out, which is nice. It's a hell of war, Dominic, and it's good to bring it home to people. No, you're right. And there's terrible shell shock. So again, another story from the book, The Fortress, there's a guy who's a corporal. He's in his 30s. He's the veteran of many battles, so he is brave.
我决定不把那段读出来，但你读了，这很好。这就是战争的地狱，多米尼克，让人们切身体会到这一点是很好的。不，你说得对。而且有可怕的炮弹休克症。所以同样，来自《要塞》这本书的另一个故事，有一个人是个下士。他三十多岁。他是多次战役的老兵，所以他很勇敢。
He's dragged into the garrison hospital, he's shouting, I want to go home. And then he took all his clothes off. He tore up his underwear. Oh, my God. He started singing hymns and then attacked the orderlies. So he's like the governor of the Bank of England in 1974. No, it wasn't the governor of the bank of England. It was the head of the civil service.
他被拖进野战医院，大喊着，我要回家。然后他脱掉了所有的衣服。他撕碎了自己的内衣。哦，天哪。他开始唱赞美诗，然后袭击了护理人员。所以他就像1974年英格兰银行行长一样。不，那不是英格兰银行行长。那是文官之首。
So William Armstrong. Yeah. Completely acceptable behavior in Ted Heath's Britain, but not in First World War, Austria, Hungary. Anyway, actually, when the Russians launched their ground attack, they didn't get anywhere. They couldn't break through the trenches. The Austrians did very well. They put up a very plucky fight. Some of these forts that they defended, they became kind of legendary.
也就是威廉·阿姆斯特朗。是的。这在希思首相统治下的英国是完全可以接受的行为，但在第一次世界大战的奥匈帝国可不行。无论如何，实际上，当俄国人发动地面进攻时，他们毫无进展。他们无法突破战壕。奥地利人表现得非常好。他们进行了非常勇敢的抵抗。他们防守的一些堡垒成为了传奇般的存在。
There's a fault called I-WOM. And the defence there, I was mean about academics, but the defence was led by somebody called Dr. Istvan Belek, who was a Budapest lawyer. and he led this sort of Helms-deep-style defence of this fort against the Crimean Regiment, kind of hand-to-hand fighting, until they can be relieved by more Hungarian troops. So that's kind of good news for the Austrians. And then they hear tremendous news from the north. Because as we heard last time, Hindenburg and Ludendorf, the cracked detectives, have driven the Russians out of East Prussia at Tannenberg and at the Missyrian lakes,
有一个叫I-WOM的堡垒。那里的防守——我之前对学者刻薄过，但防守是由一个叫伊什特万·贝莱克博士的人领导的，他是一名布达佩斯律师，他领导了这场对克里米亚团的、类似《指环王》中圣盔谷风格的堡垒保卫战，进行了近身肉搏战，直到更多匈牙利军队前来解围。所以这对奥地利人来说是个好消息。然后他们听到了来自北方的巨大利好消息。因为正如我们上次所听到的，兴登堡和鲁登堡这两位出色的将领，已经在坦能堡和马祖尔湖将俄国人赶出了东普鲁士，
and now they're moving south towards Warsaw. So the Russians have to lift this siege and they move all their troops north to face the Germans. So for the people of Jemischl, this is brilliant news. And on the 9th of October, they are relieved by the Austrian Field Army, which has returned from licking its wounds. So after a month, the siege appears to be over.
现在他们正向南朝华沙挺进。所以俄国人不得不解除这场围困，把所有的军队调往北方去对付德国人。所以对于普热梅希尔的人民来说，这是个天大的好消息。10月9日，他们被从舔舐伤口归来的奥地利野战军解救了。因此在一个月后，围困似乎结束了。
And you could ask, well, so what, does it matter? In his book, The Fortress, Alexander Watson, says it absolutely does matter because if the Russians had taken the fortress then, they would never have had a better chance to strike into the heart of the Habsburg Empire, get to Budapest, knock Austria, Hungary out of the war. The war genuinely could have been over by Christmas. But because they didn't take it, because these blokes, lawyers and whatnot held out, the Russians have missed their best opportunity to bring the war to a speedy conclusion. However, as we've said before, Fortunes change ridiculously quickly on the eastern front. So by late October, so after barely a month, the pendulum has swung again. The Russians have just won two victories that nobody has ever heard of that we talked about last time, Tom, the Battle of the Vistula, and then the Battle of Wudge. So now the Russians are heading towards Krakow and they're actually not that far from the German border. These are, by the way, a massive engagement. A million people fought in these battles insane, isn't it, that nobody's ever heard.
你可能会问，那又怎样，这重要吗？亚历山大·沃森在他的书《要塞》中说，这绝对重要，因为如果俄国人当时攻占了这座要塞，他们就再也不会有更好的机会突入哈布斯堡王朝的心脏地带，到达布达佩斯，将奥匈帝国打出局。这场战争真的可能在圣诞节前就结束了。但因为他们没有攻占，因为这些家伙——律师之流——坚守住了，俄国人错失了结束战争的绝佳机会。然而，正如我们之前所说，东线战场的局势变化荒谬地快。所以在10月下旬，也就是仅仅过了一个月后，天平再次倾斜。俄国人刚刚赢得了两场人们从未听说过的胜利，也就是我们上次谈到的，汤姆，维斯瓦河战役，然后是罗兹战役。所以现在俄国人正朝克拉科夫进发，他们离德国边境其实已经不远了。顺便说一句，这是一场规模巨大的战役。一百万人在这场战役中厮杀，没有人听说过这事，不是很疯狂吗？
heard of them. I mean, I'm sure they have in Russia, but not here. So now the Russians are back. And now, yet again, the Austrians have to retreat. Now, at this point, some of the officers in the fortress said, come on, we held out once, but we cannot handle a second siege. We've run up. We don't have the supplies. We don't have. And actually, since we've given the army time to rebuild anyway, what's the point? Why don't we evacuate the city, evacuate the garrison, blow up the forts and cut our losses. The problem is that the success of that first siege was the only victory for the Austrians worth celebrating in the early days of the war. So it's become completely bound up with Conrad's personal prestige.
听说过它们。我的意思是，在俄国他们肯定听说过，但这里没有。所以现在俄国人又回来了。现在，奥地利人又一次不得不撤退。这时，要塞里的一些军官说，拜托，我们顶住过一次，但我们应付不了第二次围困。我们已经山穷水尽了。我们没有物资。我们没有……而且反正既然我们已经给了军队重建的时间，那还有什么意义？我们为什么不撤离这座城市、撤离守军、炸毁堡垒并减少损失呢。问题在于，第一次围困的成功是战争初期唯一值得奥地利人庆祝的胜利。所以它完全与康拉德的个人声望绑定在了一起。
His only chance of basically, you know, building up his reputation, is to hold on to Pushimishol. And he, if he'd written it off, possibly he would have been sacked then, and then it's good by marrying Gina. So he says, right, I want you to prepare for another siege. I'm sure you'll do brilliantly. you were heroic and successful last time. I'm sure you will be again. The next day, however, the garrison told you should write your farewell letters to your families.
他唯一能够基本上，你知道的，建立自己声誉的机会，就是死守普热梅希尔。而且他，如果他放弃了，他可能当时就被撤职了，那跟吉娜结婚也就泡汤了。所以他说，好，我要你们为主的另一场围困做好准备。我相信你们会表现得极其出色。你们上次表现英勇并且成功了。我相信你们这次还会一样。然而，第二天，守军就被告知，你们应该给家人写诀别信了。
That's not a good sign, is that? Which I don't think inspires much confidence. That same day, which is the 3rd of November, posters go up across the city, telling all the civilians to get out. Again, that's not a good sign. No. And the police literally go door to door, saying if you haven't packed, you know, get to the station. Come on, just grab your essentials. Well, it's lucky that the Austrian Railway service is performing heroically in these early months of the war then, isn't it? Because surely they've laid on loads of trains and there won't be a mad crush trying to get on the trains. No, well, no. So total pandemonium, not enough trains. They have to leave behind 30,000 people. And in his book, Catastrophe Max Hastings, tells an awful story about this woman who fights her way into this
这不是一个好兆头，不是吗？我觉得这并没有激发多少信心。就在同一天，也就是11月3日，全城到处都贴出了海报，通知所有平民撤离。同样，这不是一个好兆头。是的。而且警察挨家挨户地通知，如果你还没收拾行李，你知道的，去火车站。快点，带上必需品就行。好吧，这么说来，奥地利铁路局在战争的头几个月里表现得像英雄一样，这倒挺幸运的，不是吗？因为他们肯定安排了大量列车，大家不会为了上车而挤得头破血流。不，好吧，没有。所以是一片混乱，列车根本不够。他们不得不留下3万人。马克斯·黑斯廷斯在他的著作《灾难》中，讲了一个可怕的故事，讲的是一个妇女如何拼命挤进
carriage with her three children. She finally gets in the place in the carriage. Train starts pulling out. she breathes a sigh of relief. She looks around. She can see only two children just out the window. On the platform, she can see the youngest child, her three-year-old son, standing there weeping in terror. Oh, no. All the time, the Russians are coming. And by the 8th of November, they have encircled the fortress once again. And now, to quote Alexander Watson, darkness descended over the conquered land. So, Dominic, huge tension. Can this great Austrian fortress withstand? a second siege, will they be able to hold out or will the Russians break through? And you mentioned how there are large numbers of Jews in this landscape. And you've intimated that things don't turn out well for them. So we'll hear about them too. So come back after the break. This episode is brought to you by Uber. Now, do you know that feeling when someone shows up for you when you need it most. We all need that sometimes, and Uber knows it.
带着三个孩子的车厢。她终于在车厢里占了个地方。火车开始启动了。她松了一口气。她环顾四周。她透过窗户只能看到两个孩子。在站台上，她看到最小的孩子，她三岁的儿子，站在那里惊恐地哭泣。哦，不。与此同时，俄军正在逼近。到了11月8日，他们再次包围了这座要塞。现在，用亚历山大·沃森的话来说，黑暗降落在这片被征服的土地上。所以，多米尼克，局势高度紧张。这座伟大的奥地利要塞能抵挡住第二次围攻吗？他们能坚守住，还是俄军会突破防线？你刚才提到这片土地上有大量犹太人。而且你暗示过，他们的结局不太好。所以我们也会听到关于他们的消息。休息一下，马上回来。本集节目由 Uber 赞助播出。你知道那种当最需要的时候有人挺身而出的感觉吗？我们有时都需要这种支持，而 Uber 深知这一点。
Uber isn't just a ride or a meal delivered. It's showing up no matter what. Like for your long-distance friends, bringing soup when they're sick, sending flowers when they're down. When it really matters, whatever it is, you show up. Where there's a will, we're on our way. Uber, on our way. Download the app today. This episode is brought to you by the Folio Society.
Uber 不仅仅是一次行程或一顿外卖。它意味着无论如何都会出现。就像对于异地的朋友，生病时送上热汤，情绪低落时送上鲜花。当真正重要的时候，无论是什么，你都会出现。有志者，事竟成，我们在路上。Uber，在路上。今天就下载应用程序吧。本集节目由 Folio 学会赞助播出。
Now, Thomas, you know, in the Middle Ages, it could take you years if you're a monk to create a manuscript. You'd have to copy it out word by word. And then after all that, the margins would be ready. And you'd put all kind of decorative elements and all kinds of gills and stuff in the margins. And it would look fantastic. So it might take often years to finish, but the finished product would then last for centuries. And that is pretty much what the folio. Society does today, only, of course, with slightly less parchment and fewer quills. Yes,
托马斯，你知道，在中世纪，如果你是一个修士，制作一份手稿可能需要花上好几年时间。你必须逐字逐句地抄写。在这之后，页边距就该处理了。你会在页边距里画各种装饰元素、各种卷须之类的东西。最后看起来会棒极了。所以完成它往往需要数年时间，但成品却能保存几个世纪。这几乎就是 Folio 学会今天所做的事情，当然，只是羊皮纸少了一点，羽毛笔也少了一点。是的，
the Folio Society takes some of the greatest works ever written, things like George Orwell's 1984, or the quests in J.R. Tolkien or Frank Herbert's June, and their team of editors and designers and artisans, they craft books that are so beautiful. They're like works of art in their own right. So each one is carefully designed with slipcases, award-winning, illustrations and covers that honor the stories inside. It doesn't just protect them. So if like me and like Tom, you think that a book should look as good as it reads, then the Folio Society very much speaks your language. Explore the world's most love stories in the most beautiful form, only at foliosociety.com. That is foliosociety.com. This episode is brought to you by Square.
Folio 学会挑选了有史以来最伟大的著作，比如乔治·奥威尔的《1984》、J.R.R. 托尔金的作品或是弗兰克·赫伯特的《沙丘》，他们的编辑、设计师和工匠团队精心制作出如此美丽的图书。它们本身就像艺术品。每一本书都经过精心设计，配有书盒、屡获殊荣的插图以及向书中故事致敬的封面。这不仅仅是对它们的保护。所以，如果你像我和汤姆一样，认为一本书的颜值应该和它的内容一样精彩，那么 Folio 学会非常符合你的心意。在 foliosociety.com 探索世界上最受喜爱的故事的最美版本。网址是 foliosociety.com。本集节目由 Square 赞助播出。
You're not just running a restaurant, you're building something big, and Square's there for all of it. Giving your customers more ways to order, whether that's in-person with Square kiosk or online. Instant access to your sales, plus the funding you need to go even bigger. And real-time insights so you know what's working, what's not, and what's next. Because when you're doing big things, your tools should to. Visit square.ca to get started. Around 8 o'clock in the morning, the Cossacks arrived in Dembitsa. The Jews, who had already survived the initial agonies,
你不仅仅是在经营一家餐厅，你还在打造伟大的事业，而 Square 全程为你保驾护航。为你的客户提供更多点餐方式，无论是通过 Square 自助点餐机进行线下点餐还是线上点餐。即时查看你的销售数据，并获得助力业务蓬勃发展所需的资金。还有实时洞察，让你清楚什么管用、什么不管用、接下来该怎么做。因为当你胸怀大志时，你的工具也应当如此。访问 square.ca 开始使用。大约在早晨8点，哥萨克人抵达了登比察。犹太人此前已经经历过最初的折磨，
were gathered in the synagogues with their wives and children. The Cossacks plunged into the Jewish houses with their horses and weapons, and what was not screwed down was smashed and flung onto the open street. Like wild beasts, they threw themselves on the defenseless women. Those who defended themselves were stabbed and trampled to death. spirited women plunged through windows badly injuring themselves but they too were not left alone by the monsters and many died in the synagogue square in agonies of pain then the synagogue street was set a light and after a short while a whole row of houses stood ablaze so this is not from a record of 1940 or
带着妻子和孩子聚集在犹太教堂里。哥萨克人骑着马、挥舞着武器冲进犹太人的房屋，凡是没固定住的东西都被砸碎并扔到了大街上。他们像野兽一样扑向手无寸铁的妇女。反抗的人被刺死并被踩踏致死。勇敢的妇女跳出窗户受了重伤，但这些魔鬼并没有放过她们，许多人在犹太教堂广场上痛苦地死去。随后，犹太教堂街被点燃，不一会儿，整排房屋陷入火海。所以这不是1940年或
1942. It is from the autumn of 1914, and it is an eyewitness account of the Russian occupation of the town of Dembitzer, which was then in Galicia. And Dominic, we've talked a lot about armies, about battles, about all of that, fluttering of flags, the piping of flutes, the fluttering of feathers in Terylian caps. But what we haven't talked about is what all this means for ordinary civilians. And I'm guessing nothing good. Nothing good at all. No, and it's actually a chance to talk about war aims and what people are wanting from the war. So the Russians have come west with them, by far, I think, the most radical transformational agenda of any major combatant. As soon as they got into Galicia, their new governor of the occupied territory, who was called Count Georgi Bobrinsky, made this clear right away.
1942年的记录。这是1914年秋天的事，这是对俄军占领当时属于加利西亚的登比察镇的目击记述。多米尼克，我们讨论了很多关于军队、战斗以及所有这些事情，旗帜飘扬、长笛吹奏、蒂罗尔帽子上的羽毛飘动。但我们没有讨论的是，这一切对普通平民意味着什么。我猜没有什么好事。绝对没有好事。是的，这其实是一个讨论战争目标以及人们对战争诉求的机会。因此，俄军向西挺进，在我看来，他们带有所有主要参赞国中最激进、最具变革性的议程。他们一进入加利西亚，新任被占领土总督格奥尔吉·博布林斯基伯爵就立刻明确了这一点。
When he got into Leviv, he gathered all the local bigwigs and the bishops, and he made a speech. And he said, the lands of Eastern Galicia are an eternal part of a single great Russia. In these lands, the true population was always Russian. Thus, the administration of this land should be based on Russian principles. We'll introduce the Russian language, Russian law, and the Russian system. Definite resonances, yeah. Now, this was very bad news for the Poles, the people who dominated the political and economic life of the towns of Galicia. It was extremely bad news for the Ukrainians, because they were told,
他一进入利沃夫，就召集了当地所有名流和主教，并发表了一讲。他说，东加利西亚的土地是一个伟大的单一俄罗斯永恒的一部分。在这些土地上，真正的居民一直是俄罗斯人。因此，这片土地的行政管理应当以俄罗斯原则为基础。我们将引入俄语、俄罗斯法律和俄罗斯制度。确实有似曾相识的感觉，是的。现在，这对波兰人来说是个非常坏的消息，波兰人主导了加利西亚城镇的政治和经济生活。这对乌克兰人来说是极其糟糕的消息，因为他们被告知：
You don't exist. Your church, your Greek Catholic church, your Ukrainian language, your separate Ukrainian, or as people would have said then, Ruthenian identity, all of these things, which interestingly had been not just tolerated, but often encouraged by the Austro-Hungarians as a counterweight to the polls. All of these things will now be erased. From now on, you are Russian, whether you like it or not. Now, if it's bad for them, it is unbelievably bad for the third ethnic group in Galicia, which are the Jews.
你们不存在。你们的教堂，你们的希腊天主教教堂，你们的乌克兰语，你们独立的乌克兰身份（或者当时人们所说的鲁塞尼亚身份），所有这些不仅被奥匈帝国容忍、甚至经常被其鼓励作为对抗波兰人的制衡力量的事物。所有这些现在都将被抹去。从现在开始，不管你愿意不愿意，你都是俄罗斯人。现在，如果这对他们来说很糟糕，那么对于加利西亚的第三大族群——犹太人来说，简直是糟透了。
Austria, Hungary was not exactly a paradise for Jews. Because we talked before when we did the rise of Nazism about the influence of Vienna's mayor, Karl Nuger, on Hitler, this kind of populist, anti-Semitic mayor. But isn't part of that because there is a resentment of Jews in Vienna, say, who have done incredibly well? Yes. So Freud, Marla. Massive cultural figures.
奥匈帝国对犹太人来说并非真正的人间天堂。因为我们之前在讨论纳粹主义崛起时谈到过维也纳市长卡尔·鲁格对希特勒的影响，这种民粹主义的、反犹太主义的市长。但部分原因难道不是因为维也纳人对犹太人取得巨大成功心存怨恨吗？是的。所以弗洛伊德、马勒。巨大的文化人物。
Jews are very prominent in the empire's high culture. There's clearly a place for them in a multinational empire. like the Habsburg Empire. And they're very loyal to the dynasty. So Franz Joseph had lifted a lot of the existing punitive laws against Jews. Franz Joseph had made a pilgrimage, effectively to Jerusalem. He made a point of meeting Jewish leaders. So there is, you know, there's clearly, Austria, Hungary is a relatively warm and welcoming home if you're an Eastern European Jew. The Russian Empire takes a very different approach to religious diversity. Russia is comfortably the most anti-Semitic country in Europe at this point.
犹太人在帝国的上层文化中非常显眼。在一个多民族帝国（如哈布斯堡帝国）中，显然有他们的一席之地。而且他们对王朝非常忠诚。因此，弗兰茨·约瑟夫取消了许多针对犹太人的现有惩罚性法律。弗兰茨·约瑟夫甚至去耶路撒冷朝圣。他特意去会见了犹太领袖。所以你知道，奥匈帝国对于东欧犹太人来说，显然是一个相对温暖和温馨的家园。俄罗斯帝国对待宗教多样性的态度则截然不同。此时的俄罗斯无疑是欧洲最反犹太主义的国家。
It's here in 1903 and it's no accident that conspiracy theorists faked the protocols of the elders of Zion. I think the interesting thing about Russian anti-Semitism is that it's obviously partly rooted in history, but it's also a very modern phenomenon. And a lot of historians say the reason it becomes so intense is that Russia is changing so much in the late 19th century, economic change, industrialization, urbanization, a lot of people who are losing. out and they, the Jews become scapegoats. So from the 1880s in Russia, the harshest anti-Semitic laws in Europe. And then a wave upon wave of pogroms. So Kiev in 1881, Kishenev very famously in 1903, Adessa in 1905, hundreds of people killed. And this is why there are
正是在1903年的这里，阴谋论者伪造《锡安长老会纪要》绝非偶然。我认为关于俄罗斯反犹太主义有趣的一点是，它显然部分植根于历史，但它也是一个非常现代的现象。许多历史学家表示，它变得如此强烈的原因是俄罗斯在19世纪后期发生了巨大变化，经济变革、工业化、城市化，许多人破产了，而犹太人成了替罪羊。因此，从19世纪80年代开始，俄罗斯出台了欧洲最严厉的反犹太法律。随之而来的是一波又一波的排犹大暴动。因此，1881年的基辅、1903年极具名气的基什尼奥夫、1905年的敖德萨，数百人被杀。这就是为什么会出现
kind of waves of emigration, aren't they coming to Britain and then even more to the United States. Exactly. So if you're, you know, a Jewish village. or a townsman or whatever in 1914, in Galicia, and you hear the Russians are coming, you are terrified. And people have a particular dread of the Cossacks. You open this half by doing a reading about the Cossacks, because the Cossacks see themselves as the defenders of Russian imperialism and Russian orthodoxy, and they have a blood-soaked reputation. They have been the shock troops in a lot of these pogroms.
一波又一波的移民潮，不是吗？他们来到英国，然后更多地去往美国。没错。所以如果你在1914年的加利西亚是一个犹太村庄的居民或城镇居民，当你听说俄军要来时，你会吓坏的。人们对哥萨克人有一种特殊的恐惧。你这集开头讲了一段关于哥萨克人的内容，因为哥萨克人将自己视为俄罗斯帝国主义和俄罗斯正统信仰的捍卫者，他们有着血迹斑斑的名声。他们一直是许多次排犹大暴动中的突击队。
And as we've heard, they completely live up to this horrendous billing. As soon as they cross the frontier, there were stories about them attacking. Jewish villages, looting shops, killing people, raping people, all of this. And the very worst pogrom was in Leviv at the end of September. It's a common story in the First World War that there'll be a rumor goes around, oh, our troops are being attacked by partisans or whatever. So this is what happened in Leviv, and there the Cossacks were given permission. Their commander said, okay, the gloves are off, you can go and punish people, do what you like. And they ran amok, they slaughtered almost 50 people, and they rounded up 300 people for
正如我们所听到的那样，他们完全符合这种可怕的形象。他们一过边境，就不断传出他们袭击犹太村庄、洗劫店铺、杀害平民、强奸妇女等各种故事。最严重的大暴动发生在9月底的利沃夫。第一次世界大战中有一个常见的故事，就是会流传着这样的谣言，哦，我们的部队正遭到游击队或诸如此类的袭击。利沃夫发生的就是这种情况，当时哥萨克人得到了授权。他们的指挥官说，好了，不用客气了，你们可以去惩罚他们，随心所欲吧。于是他们大开杀戒，屠杀了近50人，并搜捕了300人准备
deportation to the east. It's not yet genocidal. It's nothing, I think that would be a massive overstatement. However, the direction of travel, I would say, is pretty ominous. A lot of the Russian commanders are obsessively anti-Semitic. The chief of staff, who's a guy called General Yanushkiewicz, is even by Russian standards, he's a pathological anti-Semite. And so there's no effort made to moderate the violence at all. In fact, officers will have Jewish people black, They'll blackmail them. They'll loot their shops and houses. They have them whipped in the streets, hanged and so on. And then in the spring of 1915, the Russians begin mass deportations, huge deportations of Jews to camps in the East. So this is the shadow that is hanging. This is the threat that awaits the people of Shemichel in the turn of 1914 into 1915. Of course, the Russians haven't taken the city yet. They have learned their lesson from the first seats. They're not going to do this kind of frontal attack, they're going to starve the defenders out. Now, the guy commanding the fortress, this man called General Kusmanek, who is a policeman's son from
将其流放到东方。这还不是灭绝性的。我认为这绝非事实，这样说未免太夸张了。然而，大体趋势可以说是相当不祥的。许多俄军指挥官都有着偏执的反犹太主义倾向。参谋长是一个名叫亚努什凯维奇将军的人，甚至按俄罗斯的标准来看，他也是一个病态的反犹太主义者。因此，根本没有做任何努力来缓和暴力。事实上，军官们会勒索犹太人。他们会洗劫犹太人的店铺和房屋。他们让犹太人在街上挨鞭子、被绞死等等。然后在1915年春天，俄军开始大规模驱逐犹太人，将他们大量驱逐到东方的集中营。这就是悬在头顶的阴影。这就是1914转入1915年之际，普热梅希尔（Shemichel）人民所面临的威胁。当然，俄军还没有攻占这座城市。他们从第一次围攻中吸取了教训。他们不会进行这种正面进攻，而是要将守军围困至死。现在，指挥这座要塞的人，这个名叫库斯马内克将军的人，是一个来自
Transylvania. He was an archive man, Tom. He was a desk officer who had worked in the Austrian War Archive. So we have laughed at the idea of academics and lawyers manning the defences, but actually they're coming out of this tremendously well, aren't they? It was a cheap shot, but irresistible, but maybe cheap nonetheless. So this bloke does very well. He says, you know, we're going to, he runs the city very smoothly under the circumstances. He sets up suit kitchens for people who haven't got any food. He gets nuns to cook hundreds of meals for them a day. However, he's really up against it because the conditions are, it's your classic kind of siege conditions.
特兰西瓦尼亚的警察的儿子。汤姆，他是个档案工作者。他是一个曾在奥地利战争档案馆工作过的内勤军官。所以我们曾嘲笑由学者和律师来把守防线这种想法，但实际上他们干得极其出色，不是吗？这是一个便宜的讽刺，但又让人无法抗拒，不过或许确实有些廉价。所以这家伙干得很棒。他说，你知道的，我们要，在那种情况下，他把这座城市管理得井井有条。他为没有食物的人设立了汤厨房。他让修女们每天为他们烹饪数千顿饭。然而，他确实面临巨大困境，因为环境就是典型的围城环境。
So piles of unburied excrement in the streets, disease, rampant, drains overflowing, nothing to eat, all of this kind of thing. You know, the stuff you would see in siege is going back to antiquity. but there are some new elements. So at the beginning of December, the 1st of December, people look up, they hear something in the sky above the city, and they see a plane, and people come out actually to stare at it, watch it, and then they see these little gray balls falling out of the plane, and somebody suddenly realizes what they are and shouts.
街上堆积着未掩埋的排泄物，疾病横行，下水道溢出，没有东西吃，诸如此类的事情。你知道的，你在古代围城战中见到的那些东西。但也有一些新元素。因此，在12月初，即12月1日，人们抬起头，听到城市上空有什么声音，他们看到了一架飞机，人们甚至纷纷走出来盯着它看，观察它，然后他们看到一个小小的灰色球体从飞机上落下来，有人突然意识到那是什么并大喊。
They're bombs, and there are people running in panic and whatnot. This is one of the first instances in history of the aerial bombing of civilians. So in all, the Russians launched 300 bombing raids on Shemishel. They were hoping, I think, to hit the bridges. But they don't, do they? No, they miss. I mean, just throwing a ball out of a plane. I mean, it's never going to land where you think it's going to land.
那是炸弹，人们开始惊慌失措地奔跑等。这是历史上对平民进行空中轰炸的最早实例之一。因此，俄军总共对普热梅希尔发动了300次轰炸。我想，他们是希望击中桥梁的。但他们没有，对吧？不，他们打偏了。我是说，从飞机上扔下一个球，它永远不可能落到你以为它会落到的地方。
However, you know, it's not comedy. A dozen people were killed. Two dozen people were injured. There's a story, I think it's an Alexander Watson's account, of a girl, she had half her head cleaved off by shrapnel and had to be rushed twitching to hospital. But the bombings, as is always in history, The bombings terrify and are poor people, but they don't sap their will to resist because
然而，这不是喜剧。十几人丧生。二十几人受伤。我记得在亚历山大·沃森的记述中有一个故事，一个女孩的一半头颅被弹片削掉，不得不抽搐着被紧急送往医院。但轰炸正如历史上常有的一样，轰炸恐吓并折磨了可怜的人民，但并没有动摇他们抵抗的意志，因为
people think, well, the Russians are barbarians. They're monsters to do this. We can never give into them. So Christmas comes and the city is still under siege. In Eastern Europe, the big day is Christmas Eve. The defenders tried to put up trees and they were given special food, but it's all a bit sad. Alexander Watson quotes this guy, Lieutenant Staniswof Gajach. And he says in his diary, I couldn't stop thinking about my wife and children. The day was was really difficult, even getting through it was so hard. He gathers his kind of platoon or whatever to celebrate the Holy Day and everybody starts crying. And then he had dinner with his fellow officers and they tried to light candles and sink carols. But again, they all start crying.
人们认为，俄军是野蛮人。做这种事简直是怪物。我们绝不能向他们屈服。圣诞节到了，这座城市依然处于围困之中。在东欧，最重要的日子是平安夜。守军试图竖起圣诞树，还分到了特殊的食物，但这一切都有点悲凉。亚历山大·沃森引用了这位名叫斯坦尼斯瓦夫·加亚奇中尉的话。他在日记中写道，我无法停止想念我的妻子和孩子。这一天真的很难熬，甚至熬过去都那么艰难。他召集了他的排或类似编制的人来庆祝这个神圣的节日，所有人都开始哭泣。然后他和同僚军官共进晚餐，他们试图点燃蜡烛并唱颂歌。但同样，他们都开始哭泣。
Mostovsky, Stumpf, the captain, all quietly cried. And this is the one moment in the story actually where the Russians, belying their reputation, behaved, I think, very well. Because When Austrian patrols went out of the city that day, they found little parcels of bread and sausages and sugar in no man's land with cards wishing them a happy Christmas. Oh, that is nice. And Alexander Watson quotes a lovely example. Gallant nights, at so great a holiday as Christmas Eve, we wish you and your family is the best, and wish you return healthy to your nearest and dearest. We shall not disturb you on Christmas Day as you eat your supper and talk of your loved ones. As a mark of our fraternal greetings, we break this holy wafer with you.
莫斯托夫斯基、施通普夫船长，所有人都默默地哭了。而这其实是故事中唯一一个俄罗斯人摒弃其名声、表现得非常好的时刻。因为当奥地利巡逻队那天走出城市时，他们发现在无人区里放着一小包面包、香肠和糖，旁边还有祝他们圣诞快乐的卡片。哦，那太好了。亚历山大·沃森引用了一个极好的例子。勇敢的骑士们，在圣诞夜这样一个伟大的节日里，我们祝愿您和您的家人一切都好，祝您健康地回到亲人身边。在您吃晚餐和谈论挚爱的时候，我们在圣诞节不会打扰您。作为我们兄弟般问候的标志，我们与您分享这神圣的圣饼。
your comrades outside the Siedliska forts. I mean, that's quite sweet in a way, isn't it? Yeah, so another Christmas truce on the Eastern Front as well as one on the Western Front. Yeah, and as on the Western Front, as soon as it's over, things get very dark indeed. Once we're into January, they've run out of food inside the fort. They basically start eating all their horses. But they haven't got on to the rats yet. They haven't got onto the rats.
你们在谢利利斯卡（Siedliska）堡垒外的战友。从某种意义上说，这挺温馨的，不是吗？是的，东线也出现了另一次圣诞休战，西线也是如此。是的，就像在西线一样，一旦结束，情况就立刻变得非常黑暗。一进入一月份，堡垒内部的食物就耗尽了。他们基本上开始吃所有的马匹。但他们还没沦落到吃老鼠的地步。他们还没沦落到吃老鼠。
No, it's not quite the Sieger-Leningrad in the Second World War. But unless something drastically changes, Shemichel is doomed. But you know what? General Conrad is waiting in the wings for another crack. He hasn't given up. So he's going to come to the rescue. If there's one man you want to come to the rescue, it's this man with an unbroken track record of catastrophic failure.
不，这还不完全是第二次世界大战中的列宁格勒围城战。但除非发生剧烈变化，普热梅希尔（Shemichel）就注定要灭亡了。但你知道吗？康拉德将军正在一旁伺机发动另一次进攻。他还没有放弃。所以他要来救援了。如果要找一个人来救援，那就是这个有着一连串灾难性失败记录的人。
The Gandalf the White of the Eastern Front. So his men have been holed up in the Carpathian Mountains. They've been camping in heavy snow and driving rain. They've all got frostbites and hypothermia. Another commander might say, I'll let them rest a bit and thaw out before throwing them back into the fray. But Comrade, as we know, is a born optimist. So on the 23rd of January, he says, right, I want 175,000 men to go down out the mountains, retake the mountain passes from the Russians, get down into Galicia, relieve the city. By any standards, this is a big ask, as people say.
东线的白袍甘道夫。所以他的手下一直被困在喀尔巴阡山脉中。他们一直在大雪和暴雨中露营。他们都得了冻疮和低体温症。换作别的指挥官，可能会说，在把他们重新投入战场之前，先让他们休息一会儿，暖和暖和。但正如我们所知，康拉德是个天生的乐观主义者。因此，在1月23日，他说，好吧，我要175,000人从山上下来，从俄军手中夺回山口，进入加利西亚，解救这座城市。无论按什么标准来看，正如人们所说，这都是一个艰巨的要求。
And actually, what happens next is the Carpathian campaign. Now, again, this is one of those things that I think in the English-speaking world, most people have no idea this ever happened. I put my hand up, I plead guilty. It's one of the most horrific campaigns of the whole war. So hundreds of thousands of Austro-Hungarians are trying to fight their way out to these mountains. They're in snow blizzards. The temperatures are below minus 20 degrees Celsius.
而事实上，接下来发生的就是喀尔巴阡山战役。现在，这也是英语世界里大多数人根本不知道发生过的事情之一。我举手承认，我难辞其咎。这是整个战争中最可怕的战役之一。数十万奥匈帝国官兵试图在这些山脉中杀出一条血路。他们身处暴风雪中。气温降至零下20摄氏度以下。
They don't have winter gear. I mean, we talk about people having the wrong shoes, Tom. I thought of them have got shoes made of paper. Would you wear a paper shoe in a snow blizzard? No, I wouldn't. I did wear a pair of trainers that came to pieces when I walked up Mount Helvallin in the late district. All right. So you know exactly what they've been through.
他们没有冬装。我是说，我们谈到有人鞋子不对，汤姆。我想其中有些人的鞋子是用纸做的。你会穿着纸鞋在暴风雪中行走吗？不，我不会。我在晚期地区的赫瓦林山散步时，确实穿过一双走几步就散架的运动鞋。好吧。所以你完全知道他们经历了什么。
And there was kind of sleet blowing in and we ran into a squad of the SAS who told me off. They told, yeah, they said, you're an idiot. Look at your shoes. Oh, no. Which makes me ask, why is their kit not better? Because surely if anyone is used to alpine conditions, it's the Austrians. It's a Tyrolean. Kaiser Yeager. Their shoes are rotted. They've rotted and their supply networks have failed and
当时有雨夹雪吹进来，我们碰上一队SAS士兵，他们把我训斥了一顿。他们说，是的，他们说，你是个傻瓜。看看你的鞋。哦，不。这让我不禁要问，为什么他们的装备不能更好一些？因为如果说有什么人习惯了高山环境，那肯定是奥地利人。是蒂罗尔人。帝国的猎兵。他们的鞋子都腐烂了。鞋子烂了，补给网络也崩溃了，
haven't they got kind of a nice ski gear? They have not. They have not. Well, I'll give you the proof of this. After two weeks, they've lost two thirds of their strength. Some of them have been killed. Some of them have died of disease. But loads of them have actually frozen to death in their sleep. Now, we began with your favorite regiment, didn't we? The Tyroly and Kaiser Yeager. The guys with the feathers. They've been involved in this because they're freezing to death. I mean, you'd think they'd be used to this in the Tyrol, but no. And I mentioned Nick Lloyd's book on the Eastern Front. He quotes one of their memoirs, and would you like to read it, Tom, since you love them so much?
难道他们没有那种不错的滑雪装备吗？他们没有。他们根本没有。好吧，我给你证据。两个星期后，他们失去了三分之二的兵力。其中一些人被杀。一些人死于疾病。但实际上有许多人在睡梦中冻死了。现在，我们从你最喜欢的团开始讲的，对吧？蒂罗尔和帝国的猎兵。那些戴着羽毛的小伙子。他们卷入了这场战斗，因为他们快要冻死了。我的意思是，你以为他们在蒂罗尔会习惯这种天气，但并没有。我提到了尼克·劳埃德关于东线作战的书，他引用了其中一篇回忆录，汤姆，既然你那么喜欢他们，你想读一读吗？
The scene was suffused with three colours. The ash and white of the endless fields of snow, the grave black of the endless mountain forests, the blood red of the flames of battle. The sky stretched boundlessly, mercilessly over the death and suffering of hundreds and thousands of soldiers. The Carpathian front consumed men at an alarming rate. It wore them down like a hammer, day in and day out, week after week, blow after blow, coming down on them with unceasing bigger. So that is the worst ski holiday of all time, isn't it? It is a terrible skiing holiday.
这个场景弥漫着三种颜色。无尽雪原的灰白，无尽山地森林的阴森漆黑，战火烈焰的血红。天空无边无际、毫不留情地笼罩着成百上千士兵的死亡与苦难。喀尔巴阡山前线以惊人的速度吞噬着士兵。它像一把铁锤一样消耗着他们，日复一日，周复一周，一次又一次的打击，带着不减的活力向他们砸来。所以这是有史以来最糟糕的滑雪假期，对吧？这真是一个糟糕的滑雪假期。
And actually the blokes who are dying are not just from the Tyrol. They're not just Austrians. They are Hungarians, their Czechs, their Poles, their Croats, whatever. And as every day passes, their faith in the army and their loyalty to the empire and to the monarchy is just leaching away. Of course it is, because they have been, as they say, betrayed by their own commanders for a cause that seems to them baffling. Now, meanwhile, back at the fortress, the people there are freezing too. They don't have winter uniforms. They've only got their summer gear. They are these sort of ghostly shrunken figures. They're finishing
事实上，死去的家伙不仅来自蒂罗尔。他们不只是奥地利人。他们是匈牙利人，捷克人，波兰人，克罗地亚人，诸如此类。而且随着每一天的过去，他们对军队的信念、对帝国和君主制的忠诚正在一点点流失。当然是这样，因为正如他们所说，他们被自己的指挥官为了一个对他们来说莫名其妙的事业给出卖了。现在，与此同时，回到要塞，那里的人们也在挨冻。他们没有冬季制服。他们只有夏季装备。他们就像是那种幽灵般萎缩的身影。他们正在吃掉
off the horses now. They're having to dilute their flower with birch wood. They're collapsing every day with starvation, 25,000 men are in the hospital with hunger and exposure, and the Russians are just pounding them the whole time with their heavy guns. So by mid-March, Conrad finally has to accept defeat, and he sends a message to the fortress, and he says, you know, we're not coming. Basically, you're doomed. But then he says, very like Hitler or Stalingrad or something, Imperial Honor demands that you don't surrender, you should go down fighting. And actually this bloke General Kuzmarnik, the archivist, says fine, and he actually cobbles together some assault troops. It says, right, we'll do one last breakout. This is a disaster. They get lost in the
马匹。他们不得不把面粉和白桦木掺在一起。他们每天都有人因饥饿而倒下，有25000名士兵因饥饿和暴露躺在医院里，而俄国人则一直在用重炮轰炸他们。因此到三月中旬，康拉德终于不得不接受失败，他向要塞发送了一条消息，他说，你知道，我们不会来了。基本上，你们注定要灭亡了。但随后他说，非常像希特勒或斯大林格勒那样，帝国荣誉要求你们不要投降，你们应该战死到底。实际上，库兹马尼克将军这个档案管理员说，好吧，他居然拼凑了一些突击部队。他说，好吧，我们要进行最后一次突围。这是一场灾难。他们在
snow. The Russians basically unleash a storm of gunfire at them, and they have to fall back into the fortress. So on the 21st of March, Kuzmarnik convenes his senior officers, and they all agree, there's no point going on. Like, it's all over. It's been months, and we're not going to be relieved. But they decide to go out literally with a bang. They want to destroy everything of value before they surrender and make sure that the Russians march into a ruined city. So overnight, they empty their guns at the Russian lines. Sort of thunder of the guns, people said, were so intense that nobody could sleep. And then at 6 o'clock the next morning, the series of enormous explosions rip through
雪中迷路了。俄国人基本上对他们发动了枪林弹雨的猛烈攻击，他们不得不退回要塞。因此在3月21日，库兹马尼克召集了他的高级军官，他们都一致认为，再坚持下去没有意义了。就像，一切都结束了。几个月过去了，我们不会被解救了。但他们决定轰轰烈烈地大干一场。他们想在投降前摧毁所有有价值的东西，并确保俄国人走进一座废弃的城市。因此，在夜间，他们把枪口对准了俄国人的防线。人们说，那种枪声的轰鸣声如此强烈，以至于谁也无法入睡。然后第二天早上6点，一系列巨大的爆炸声响彻了
these forts. People said it was like volcanoes erupting around the city, huge, great clouds of smoke and rubble raining down. And then they blew up the bridges over the river sand. And people said it was like the day of judgment, kind of pillars of fire and black smoke everywhere and the earth torn open and all of this. And at breakfast, Kuzmarnik sent a message to the Russians. He said, I surrender the open city and await your command with no conditions.
这些堡垒。人们说，这就像火山在城市周围爆发，巨大厚重的烟云和瓦砾雨点般落下。然后他们炸毁了桑河上的桥梁。人们说，这就像审判日一样，到处都是火柱和黑烟，大地裂开，诸如此类。在早餐时，库兹马尼克给俄国人发了一条消息。他说，我向这座不设防的城市投降，无条件听候你们的处置。
And then at nine o'clock, the Russians marched into the center of this city. Now, what happened to the defenders? It's an interesting story. 120,000 men, masses, taken prisoner. and these were just sum of two million Austro-Hungarian prisoners of war. Yeah, mind-boggling. Two million people. I mean, so large that the numbers just cease to have any meaning.
然后在九点钟，俄国人开进了这座城市的中心。现在，防守方怎么样了？这是一个有趣的故事。12万名士兵，成群结队，被俘虏了。而这只是两百万奥匈帝国战俘中的一部分。是的，令人匪夷所思。两百万人。我的意思是，数字太大了，以至于数字本身失去了任何意义。
Right, exactly. You can't imagine what does it look like? You can't even get your head around it. Now, officers, by and large, were well-treated. Remember when we did Peter the Great in the Great Northern War and what happened to the Swedes? It's actually the same story. The officers tend to be well-treated, so Kuzmanek ended up under house arrest in Kiev. But the men, different story.
对，完全如此。你无法想象它是什么样子？你甚至无法理解它。现在，军官们大体上受到了善待。还记得我们在大北方战争中讲彼得大帝以及瑞典人遭遇了什么吗？其实是同一个故事。军官们往往会受到优待，所以库兹马尼克最终在基辅被软禁。但士兵们就不同了。
They were driven with whips by Cossacks to the railway stations and then packed into cattle trucks to go to camps in Kazakhstan and Uzbekistan. By the time they got there, many were dead from starvation or cold or whatever, and in the camps, many thousands more died of malaria or typhus or dysentery. And the very worst fate awaited Germans and Hungarians. They were singled out. A lot of them were sent to work on this railway line that was being built from Murmansk in the north. and that was transporting military supplies from Arctic convoys from Britain. Okay, so this is again a kind of prefiguring of the Second World War. Exactly it is.
他们被哥萨克人挥舞着皮鞭赶到火车站，然后塞进运牛车里，送往哈萨克斯坦和乌兹别克斯坦的集中营。等他们到达那里时，许多人已经死于饥饿或寒冷之类的原因，而在集中营里，成千上万的人死于疟疾、斑疹伤寒或痢疾。最悲惨的命运等待着德国人和匈牙利人。他们被单独挑了出来。他们中的许多人被派去修建这条从北方的摩尔曼斯克修建的铁路。该铁路负责运送来自英国北极船队的军事物资。好的，所以这再次像是对第二次世界大战的一种预示。确实如此。
And they worked in the most horrendous conditions. So they didn't even get to sleep in kind of huts. They had to bury into the snow, sort of carve out burrows in the snow to sleep. If they faltered, they were whipped. If they fell ill, they were denied food. Basically, you know, you're finished. And some historians say the conditions in this Mermansk Railway were even worse. in 1915, 1916 or whatever,
他们在最可怕的条件下工作。所以他们甚至没有木屋可以睡觉。他们必须钻进雪里，在雪地里挖出洞穴来睡觉。如果他们步履蹒跚，就会被鞭打。如果他们生病了，就会被剥夺食物。基本上，你知道，你完了。一些历史学家说，这条摩尔曼斯克铁路上的条件甚至更糟。在1915年、1916年左右，
than in the gulags under Stalin. And how many survived? What happens to them? Well, thousands died. I don't think there's exact figures. So with all these casualty figures, there's no precise number. Some people ended up going home.
比斯大林统治下的古拉格还要糟糕。有多少人幸存下来？他们怎么样了？嗯，成千上万的人死了。我想没有确切的数字。所以对于所有这些伤亡数字，没有精确的数字。有些人最终回到了家。
So the most famous prisoners of wars to go back home were people called the Czech Legion. So they ended up, I mean, they became a factor in the Russian Civil War fighting their way on these armored trains east. Because the only way they could get back to Czech, Slovakia, The newly created Czechoslovakia was to go east all the way through Russia and then round the world. And they ended up being a kind of big faction in the Russian Civil War, which is bonkers.
因此，回国的最著名的战俘是一群被称为捷克军团的人。他们最终，我的意思是，他们成为了俄国内战中的一个因素，在这些装甲列车上一路向东战斗。因为他们返回捷克斯洛伐克唯一途径是，新创建的捷克斯洛伐克必须一路向东穿过俄罗斯，然后绕过世界。他们最终成为俄国内战中的一大派别，这太疯狂了。
But let's go back to the fall of the citadel. The news of Shemichel's fall was front-page news across the empire, total shock. Franz Joseph wept for two days because he knew that this was catastrophic for the image of the Austro-Hungarian monarchy. They'd pinned all their hopes on this place. It was their pride and joy. And now it had become a symbol of decay. So this is a war that they started. They've lost just in three months, the first three months of 1915,
但让我们回到城堡的陷落。舍梅希尔陷落的消息成了整个帝国各大报纸的头版头条，全城震惊。弗兰茨·约瑟夫哭了整整两天，因为他知道这对奥匈帝国君主制的形象来说是灾难性的。他们把所有的希望都寄托在这个地方。这是他们的骄傲和喜悦。而现在它已经成为衰落的象征。所以这是一场他们挑起的战争。仅仅在三个月内，即1915年的头三个月，
they've lost 800,000 men. They're running out of officers. And what is worse, when they lose Galicia in the northeast, a lot of their food came from these kind of farmlands. So this is very bad news for the city people in Budapest and Vienna, who depend upon the food supply. from the east. And what is more, hundreds of thousands of refugees, many of them Jewish, now flood into the sort of heart of the empire. And as they are very unpopular in other parts of the empire,
他们就损失了80万士兵。他们的军官快用完了。更糟糕的是，当他们在东北部失去加利西亚时，他们的很多食物都来自这些农田。所以这对于依赖东方食品供应的布达佩斯和维也纳的城市居民来说是个非常糟糕的消息。而且，成千上万的难民，其中许多是犹太人，现在涌入帝国的核心地带。而且由于他们在帝国的其他地方非常不受欢迎，
in Vienna and Budapest, but also in the small towns and villages in which they settle. So there are all kinds of ethnic tensions piled on top of the existing ethnic tensions within Austria, Hungary. And so as early as 1915, you can see the sort of. of sense of order breaking down. And the Austrian's allies, the Germans, at this point, starts saying, well, they're finished. They're done. So the German liaison officer at the Habsburg military headquarters wrote to Berlin and he
在维也纳和布达佩斯，以及他们定居的小城镇和村庄里也是如此。因此，在奥匈帝国原有的民族紧张局势之上，又叠加了各种民族紧张局势。所以早在1915年，你就能看到这种秩序感正在瓦解。而奥地利人的盟友德国人，此时开始说，好吧，他们完了。他们没救了。因此，哈布斯堡王朝军事总部的德国联络官给柏林写信，他
said, this empire is so rotten and so decayed, it can no longer be helped. You know, even if we win the war, this empire is not going to last. And what about Conrad and how does Gina take it? Conrad is still going. I mean, Conrad stays in office for another couple of years, I think, unbelievably. And what Gina makes of all this. Not impressed, I imagine. Probably not impressed, but I think there's lots of censorship, of course,
说，这个帝国是如此腐朽，以至于再也无药可救了。你知道，即使我们赢得了这场战争，这个帝国也不会持久。那么康拉德呢？吉娜对此有何看法？康拉德还在继续。我的意思是，康拉德在任又维持了几年，我想，这简直令人难以置信。吉娜对这一切有何看法。我想她不会留下什么好印象。可能印象不深，但我认为当然有很多审查制度，
so she probably doesn't know what's going on. Conrad, interesting. You know who Conrad blames for all this? The Jews. No. Blames the Germans. Germans? Okay, that's original.
所以她可能不知道发生了什么。康拉德，真是有趣。你知道康拉德把这一切归咎于谁吗？犹太人。不。他怪德国人。德国人？好吧，这很有独创性。
He says, they could have given us more help. I mean, I think he's being a tiny bit ungrateful because the Germans do. The Germans basically torch their own empire to help the Austrians and destroy their own monarchy. So I think he's being a little bit of ungrateful. War, war, war. That's what he said. It's all do you care about, General Conrad von Hudsondorf. Now, meanwhile, I mentioned the circling vultures last time, and I think I might use the same metaphor this time, what I have in the notes. Yeah. So a month after the fall of this fortress, which of course is news around the world, the Italians sign a deal, secret deal, to join the Entente. And in return, they will get large swathes of Austria, Hungary, especially along the Adriatic, kind of Istria, Dalmatia. And a month after of that, Italy finally enters the war against Austria, Hungary. And if you thought the Carpathian front was bad, the Italian front.
他说，他们本可以给我们更多的帮助。我的意思是，我认为他有点忘恩负义，因为德国人确实帮了。德国人基本上为了帮助奥地利人而烧毁了自己的帝国，并摧毁了自己的君主制。所以我认为他有点忘恩负义。战争，战争，战争。这就是他说的。这就是你关心的全部，康拉德·冯·赫岑多夫将军。现在，与此同时，我上次提到了盘旋的秃鹫，我想我这次可能会在笔记中使用同样的 metaphor。是的。因此，在这座要塞陷落一个月后，这当然成了世界各地的新闻，意大利人签署了一项秘密协议，加入协约国。作为回报，他们将获得大片奥匈帝国领土，特别是在亚得里亚海沿岸，如伊斯特拉、达尔马提亚。一个月后，意大利终于对奥匈帝国宣战。如果你认为喀尔巴阡山前线很糟，那么意大利前线……
Oh, mad. Absolutely mad, blowing the tops off mountains. I've walked through a great tunnel that the Italians dug out at the side of a mountain. And I'm assuming that the Austrians did the same, and it's all absolutely for nothing. The two worst armies in history, just killing. Yeah. It's amazing stories in this book, The White War. The one that sticks in my mind is a whole load of Italians,
哦，疯狂。简直太疯狂了，把山顶都炸飞了。我曾穿过一条意大利人在山腰上凿出的大隧道。我猜奥地利人也做了同样的事情，这一切完全是徒劳。历史上最糟糕的两支军队，只是在互相残杀。是的。这本书《白色战争》里有很多精彩的故事。留在我的记忆里的一个是，一大群意大利人，
like thousands of Italians advancing up this sort of limestone scree mountain. And the Austrians at the top of the machine and shouting down saying, please stop coming. Like we will kill you all. Just go back. Don't stop. Don't come. And the Italians keep going.
成千上万的意大利人沿着这种石灰石碎石山向上推进。山顶上的奥地利人架起机枪向下大喊，请不要再上来了。我们把你们都杀光。回去吧。别停下。别上来。而意大利人还在继续前进。
And the Austrians just say, well, okay. And they kill them all. You keep saying it's a terrible story. I mean, we've already had terrible stories. But there are so many more to come. So let's just end with the city. Sheemishel, a chance to say it again one more time. So a month after the city fell, Nicholas the second turned up. He went first to Leviv and then he went to this fortress and he toured
奥地利人只好说，好吧。然后他们把他们全杀了。你老是说这是一个糟糕的故事。我的意思是，我们已经听过很多糟糕的故事了。但后面还有更多。所以让我们以这座城市结束吧。舍梅希尔，又有一个机会再说一遍。在这座城市陷落一个月后，尼古拉二世出现了。他先去了利沃夫，然后去了这座要塞，他参观了
the defences and all the people had been told hang out Russian flags from your windows and all the schools had been told to mark the day and the children instructed on how to welcome their new emperor. Nicholas, of course, is as sort of banal and putterish as ever. He said he's found very interesting and very picturesque. But this trip really mattered because the authorities used it as a spur for russification. Nicholas used the opportunity to issue a proclamation. There is no Galicia. There is rather a great Russia to the Carpathians.
防御工事，所有人都被告知在窗户上挂上俄罗斯国旗，所有的学校都被告知要纪念这一天，并指导孩子们如何欢迎他们的这位新皇帝。尼古拉当然像以往一样平庸和迂腐。他说，他觉得这里非常有趣，非常风景如画。但这次旅行真的很重要，因为当局以此为契机推行俄罗斯化。尼古拉借此机会发表了一份宣言。没有加利西亚。从喀尔巴阡山脉延伸开来的是伟大的俄罗斯。
The people of Pradeshal were told, you must adopt Russian time, Russian customs, Russian festivals, the shops must have signs in Cyrillic. Polishness must be eliminated. Polish elites deported. and Ukrainian identity erased completely. Ukrainian schools must now teach in Russian. And what about the Jews?
普热梅希尔的人民被告知，你们必须采用俄罗斯时间、俄罗斯习俗、俄罗斯节日，商店的招牌必须使用西里尔字母。必须消灭波兰特性。波兰精英被驱逐。乌克兰身份被彻底抹杀。乌克兰学校现在必须用俄语授课。犹太人呢？
Well, they pay the heaviest price of all. Since January, the Russians have been deporting Jews eastwards, but in Shemishol, they go further than anywhere else. This is the most obvious example of deportation in the entire war. In 10 days, they rounded up 17,000 people and transported them east. And why are they doing that? They don't want these lands to have any Jews in them. They want to corral the Jews.
嗯，他们付出了最沉重的代价。自1月以来，俄国人一直在向东驱逐犹太人，但在舍梅希尔，他们比任何地方都走得更远。这是整场战争中最明显的驱逐范例。在10天内，他们围捕了17000人并将他们运往东方。他们为什么要这么做？他们不希望这些土地上有任何犹太人。他们想把犹太人关进集中营。
Is that for kind of ideological reasons or because they see the Jews as Austro-Hungarian sympathizers who can't be won over? Both. They don't like Jews anyway, but they know that the Jews are loyal to the Habsburg Empire and they want to get rid for that reason. But to stress that first point, they don't like Jews anyway. And many of these, they come with anti-Semitism as part of their intellectual repertoire. are. So by May, there is not a single Jewish person left in this city. And what happens to the Jews who are deported? Some of them, I think, do get home because there are definitely Jews in Shemichel by the 1930s, though not after the 1940s. So some of them must have got back. I don't
这是出于某种意识形态的原因，还是因为他们把犹太人视为奥匈帝国的同情者，觉得无法争取？两者皆有。他们本来就不喜欢犹太人，但也知道犹太人忠于哈布斯堡王朝，所以他们想以此为由摆脱犹太人。但要强调第一点，他们本来就不喜欢犹太人。许多人来到这里时，反犹主义已经是他们知识储备的一部分。因此到五月时，这座城市里已经没有一个犹太人了。那些被驱逐的犹太人怎么样了？我想其中有些人确实回到了家，因为到20世纪30年代，普热梅希尔确实还有犹太人，尽管20世纪40年代之后就没有了。所以有些人一定回来了。我其实
actually know exactly how they did that. But the irony of all this, it was all for nothing. It really was all for nothing. Because less than two weeks after the Tsar's visit, the Germans under August von Mackinson, and again a bloat with a wrong name, launched a massive offensive in Poland, smashed the Russians, scattered their armies, the Germans went deep into occupied Galicia, and on the 2nd of June, the Germans, in turn, march into Shemichel. One of their commanders afterwards said, the joy of the liberated people was indescribable, wherever we went. German soldiers were embraced and decorated with flowers and then and handed gifts and then he adds the killer line i didn't see any austrian soldiers and that
并不确切知道他们是怎么做到的。但这一切的讽刺之处在于，这一切都是徒劳的。真的都是徒劳的。因为在沙皇访问不到两周后，在奥古斯特·冯·马肯森的率领下（又是一个名字说错的胖子），德国人在波兰发动了大规模进攻，粉碎了俄国人，打散了他们的军队，德国人深入到被占领的加利西亚，6月2日，德国人随后开进了普热梅希尔。他们的一位指挥官事后说，无论我们走到哪里，被解放人民的喜悦都是难以言表的。德国士兵受到拥抱、鲜花装扮以及礼物的赠送，接着他补上了最绝的一句：我没看到任何奥斯汀士兵，这
tells a wider story on paper the austrians are back and they've got their city back but it's actually the germans who've done it and the germans who are the real masters now and the prestige and the legitimacy of the hapsburg empire will never ever be rebuilt and so that means that all these various lands with all their different peoples their different languages their different customs that essentially the glue that had held them together is going very, very rapidly. And that, of course, has profound implications for what happens after the war, whether the central powers win or lose. Completely.
说明了一个更广泛的故事：表面上奥地利人回来了，他们收复了这座城市，但实际上是德国人干的，德国人现在才是真正的掌握者，哈布斯堡帝国的威望和合法性将永远无法重建。这意味着所有这些拥有不同人民、不同语言、不同习俗的广袤土地，实际上把它们凝聚在一起的向心力正在非常、非常迅速地消失。当然，这对于战争结束后，无论是同盟国胜利还是失败，都会产生深远的影响。完全如此。
I completely agree. So in this story, you've seen a lot of elements of things we associate with the Second World War, racial ideology, deportations, ethnic cleansing, pogroms and stuff. These, if you're Gleesian, these began in the 1910s. But as you say, since there is no rebuilding the multicultural society before the war, that means now the gloves are off and there's going to be a very, very bitter fight to see who controls it. So this is what happens when the empire collapses in Pshemishuil and its environs. There's fighting between Poles and Ukrainians.
我完全同意。所以在这个故事中，你看到了很多我们与第二次世界大战联系在一起的元素：种族意识形态、驱逐出境、种族清洗、大屠杀等等。如果你在加利西亚，这些在20世纪10年代就开始了。但正如你所说，既然无法重建战前的多元文化社会，那就意味着现在撕破脸皮了，为了争夺控制权，将会有一场非常、非常激烈的争斗。这就是帝国在普热梅希尔及其周边地区崩溃时发生的事情。波兰人和乌克兰人之间爆发了战斗。
Then it's caught up in the Polish-Bolshevik war. Then it's occupied by the Nazis and tens of thousands of its Jewish population murdered. And this is to only kind of scratch the surface of all the horror that lies ahead. Okay. So there are better places to live in the 20th century, basically. Pretty much anywhere. Yeah. I mean, that's why Timothy Snyder calls this area of the bloodlands.
然后它被卷入波兰-布尔什维克战争。接着被纳粹占领，数万名犹太居民被谋杀。这仅仅是触及了未来所有恐怖的冰山一角。好吧。所以基本上，20世纪有更好的地方可以生活。几乎任何地方都可以。是的。我的意思是，这就是蒂莫西·斯奈德将这片地区称为血地（Bloodlands）的原因。
I think basically you want to live anywhere but here. Maybe not the Congo. So that's a very cheery note, Dominic, on which to end this series. But I mean, you know, we are talking about the world going up in flames, aren't we? This is, we began this series by saying this is the great catastrophe, certainly for Europe. But you could also say for, I mean, it is authentically a world war. And I think this series has given a flavor of why it's so terrible. And of course, there is so much slaughter and misery and horror still to come.
我想基本上你想住在除了这里以外的任何地方。也许刚果除外。多明尼克，这是一个非常欢乐的音符，用来结束这个系列。但我的意思是，你知道，我们在谈论这个世界付之一炬，不是吗？我们在这个系列的开始就说过，这是一场巨大的灾难，对欧洲来说绝对如此。但你也可以说，对于——它确实是一场世界大战。我认为这个系列让人体味到为什么它如此可怕。当然，还有那么多的屠杀、苦难和恐怖还在后头。
God, you're really selling it. Well, but having said that, having said that, we are going to be back this year with a little more First World War action. And we're going to be back for our Christmas special. We will be looking at the story of the festive truce on the Western. and front, asking whether it happened, to what extent of the story is true. So a little touch of light. And actually, when we do come back to the First World, hopefully next year, I mean, there's so much to look forward to you, Tom, Zeppelin's, Gallipoli, the sinking of
天哪，你可真会推销。话虽如此，话虽如此，今年我们还将带着更多第一次世界大战的内容回归。我们将为我们的圣诞特辑回归。我们将探讨西线节日休战的故事，询问它是否发生过，这个故事在多大程度上是真实的。所以带有一点轻松的色彩。实际上，当我们回到第一次世界大战时，希望明年，我的意思是，有太多值得期待的事情了，汤姆：齐柏林飞艇、加里波利、卢西塔尼亚号的沉没、
the Lusitania, the arrival of the Italians, the wars fighting women, lots of fun things. And as always, members of the Restis History Club will be able to get those episodes early, won't they? Of course they will. Why not sign up now at The Restist History.com? Ready for next year. Bed down. But next week, something completely different because Dominic, we will be leaving your backyard,
意大利人的参战、女性参战，很多有趣的事情。而且一如既往，余烬历史俱乐部（The Rest is History Club）的会员将能够提前听到这些剧集，对吧？当然可以。为什么不现在就去 TheRestisHistory.com 注册呢？为明年做好准备。安顿下来。但下周将是一个完全不同的主题，因为多明尼克，我们将离开你的后花园——
the mountains and bogs and plains of Eastern Europe, and heading to Chatham High Street. Long promised, long awaited, finally to be delivered. And I know the excitement has been building for that. But if you want to listen to it, that's fine. But also, if you'd like to see it, because we've done it on location, you can see Chatham High Street and all its beauty and glory. Yeah, you should watch it on YouTube because I have to say
东欧的山脉、沼泽和平原，前往查塔姆商业街（Chatham High Street）。久经承诺，久违的期待，终于要呈现了。我知道大家对此一直兴奋不已。但如果你想听听声音，那没问题；不过，如果你想看看画面，因为我们是实地拍摄的，你可以看到查塔姆商业街及其所有的美丽与辉煌。是的，你应该在YouTube上观看，因为我不得不说
when we did a filming day at Chatham High Street, I think I probably haven't laughed as much as that. Not always for good reasons since I was about 12. So definitely do watch it. I think unmissable.
当我们在查塔姆商业街进行拍摄日的时候，我大概自我12岁以来就没笑得这么开心过。并不总是为了好事。所以一定要去看。我认为是不容错过的。
So we'll see you then. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那么我们到时候见。再见。再见。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。